yes
i
test one two three four five four
okay
it is okay
okay
[Music]
this impression
you
[Music]
okay
um
yes
mom
foreign
yes
oh
[Music]
now
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this hearing of the senate judiciary
committee will come to order
the committee will begin its
consideration the nomination of judge
to be the 106th justice of the supreme
court welcome judge jackson
and
to you and your family thank you senator
this is a moment
and you have much to be proud of
i know you
members and friends who want to you want
and we all look forward to hearing those
introductions when you make your own
later
at the outset i want to note that i was
sorry
this clarence thomas was hospitalized
yesterday
i speak for all the members of the
committee and wishing him a speedy
recovery
before i turn to my own opening
statement i want to briefly discuss
events and the ground rules for the
hearing
the committee has 10 minutes to make an
opening statement we'll go and see
switching between democratic and
republican senators
to made their opening statements we'll
hear from judge thomas griffith
professor lisa fairfax who are here
today to introduce
each introducer will have five minutes
to make an opening statement
finally we'll administer the oath judge
jackson and she will make
that will conclude today's events
tomorrow we'll begin
for those sitting in the audience
welcome
you could be here to witness this
historic occasion i ask
to be respectful and quiet during the
hearing
stand up unless you're entering or
exiting the room if
you asked by one of our distinguished
members of the capitol
to sit down if you refuse you'll be
escorted
let me be clear we will not tolerate any
audience any disruption will result in
immediate remote
i also ask that our audience be
respectful of the members of the cap
here today to ensure everyone's safety
without
putting statements
judge jackson as i said
again for being here today with your
family and
the supreme court has a long and storied
history
have been filled by many superb justices
whose contribution
the rule of law have stood the test of
time
but the
the reality is that the court's members
in one respect
have never
really reflected the nation they served
when the supreme court met for the very
first time
of 1790 in the exchange building in
there were nearly 700 000 slaves without
citizenship in this new nation of nearly
4 million
neither african americans nor
right to vote there was no equal justice
for a majority of people living in
america
it's more than 230 years the supreme
court has had
justices
108 have been white men as two
justices have been men of color only
have served on the court and just one a
woman of color
justice has been a black woman
you judge
can be the first
it's not easy being the first
often you have to be the best in some
ways the bravest
you're not prepared to face that kind of
heat that kind of scrutiny that
of the national spotlight
but your presence here today
is to brave this process will give
inspiration to millions of
who see themselves in you as i mentioned
to you i was
the steps of the supreme court this
morning to see the rally in
there were so many young
african-american women
there
seeing your pursuit as part
in other important ways though the
nominees have come before us
president
because he knew your qualifications are
outstanding
and he knows you you've appeared three
previous times and
confirmed with bipartisan support
and your professional record if
experience tell us what kind of lawyer
what kind of judge
and what kind of person you really are
you're guiding
found in your life and in your work that
the constitution
americans not just the wealthy and
powerful the judge
favoritism and that the judiciary must
live up
ways and above the entrance equal
justice under
so today is proud day for america we've
come along
1790 and we know that we still have able
to form a more perfect union
it's a moment
something that the late senator from
illinois paul simon
said
to judge ruth bader ginsburg at her
hearing
he said you faith
harsher judge than this committee
and that is the
and that judgment is likely to revolve
around the question
did she restrict freedom or did she
expand it
statement time and again because it asks
a vital question
street judge us
judge jackson
will remember you as a justice who never
stopped working to defend
but i also ask the members of this
committee as
this landmark confirmation process to
consider how
each senator as we face our
constitutional
advise and consent
this moment also
i think president barack obama another
trailblazer said
illinoisian when the late justice john
paul stevenson
president obama said while we cannot
replace
experience or wisdom i will seek someone
with similar similar
an independent mind a record of
excellence and integrity
dedication to the rule of law and a keen
understanding of
the daily lives of america
much like justice steve
cannot replace justice briar
but with you we have a nominee who
embodies the same qualities
outstanding justices
you're independent-minded and understand
the critical importance of judicial
independence
your records and integrity from the
championship debate team
palmetto senior high school
to harvard and harvard
to your three judicial clerkships your
work as a
defender a lawyer in private practice a
member
mission a federal district judge and
circuit court judge
throughout your career you've been a
champion for the rule of law
even at the risk of public criticism
sentencing commission a bipartisan group
which reflects of american thinking on
law enforcement you set out
the truly represented congressional
intent when it came to
criminal sentence and fair
and you did it by finding
some common ground
during your tenure on that commission
95
of the commission's votes were either
unanimous
for example the commission implementing
act a law that i negotiated within
senator jeff sessions that reduced the
infamous 100 to 1 crack powder
sentencing disparity
and you joined every one of your
colleagues to make that change to the
sentencing guidelines retroactive
you gave a powerful speech and i'm going
to quote it you said there is no excuse
for insisting that those who are serving
excessive sentences under the long
disputed and now discredited prior
guideline must carry on as though none
of this has happened
the vote in favor of retroactivity was
unanimous on the commission republicans
and democrats shared your view
and you've gone to great lengths to
explain how the law affects real people
indeed with your nomination we can be
confident that the court its role and
its decisions will be more
understandable to the american public in
your time on the bench you've taken the
time to explain your decisions and their
consequences
when you're before this committee just
last year for your dc circuit hearing
you described how you quote take extra
care to communicate with parties you
added and i quote i speak to them
directly and not just to their lawyers i
use their names i explain every stage of
the proceeding because i want them to
know what's going on
as a result of that approach you've made
the law more approachable to litigants
and american people
the cameras and the lights here today
can make it easy to forget that at its
core the responsibility you seek is one
of service
and i'm fully confident you'll serve
americans from all walks of life all
backgrounds fairly and faithfully
now there may be some who claim
without a shred of evidence that you'll
be a rubber stamp for this president
for these would-be critics i have four
words
look at the record
your complete record has been scoured by
this committee on four different
occasions
all of your nearly 600 written opinions
read and reread 12 000 pages of
transcripts meeting minutes and other
materials for the sentencing commission
your sworn testimony before the
committee less than a year ago
every published and reported word you've
written or spoken your detailed answers
to lengthy questions for those who say
they need more i would answer that
you've sat down personally with every
member on this diocese of the committee
democrats and republicans a fair review
of all of this makes clear your values
and guiding principles
you have ruled for and against
presidents and administrations of both
parties you've ruled for prosecutors and
for defendants
you've ruled for workers and for their
employers and you've been faithful to
the law not to any person or political
cause
now there may be others who allege that
you're before us today is a product of
the campaign of dark money groups
once again your record in the process
that led to this nomination believe that
claim
to suggest that you're here merely
because an organization supports you
ignores your qualifications and the
broad range of support you bring to this
in selecting you as his nominee
president biden undertook a transparent
selection process he sought the input of
senators from both parties senator
grassley and i met in the oval room with
the president he invited us to pray for
any nominees that we care to do at the
end of the day the president alone chose
you
he's put his faith in you to deliver
justice the highest level the court i
share that faith
in announcing your nomination the
president spoke to many reasons that you
deserve to sit on the high court he
noted the perspective you'll bring as a
former member of the sentencing
commission as the first justice since
thurgood marshall with considerable
criminal defense experience and is the
only the second current justice only the
second
to serve as a federal trial court judge
he also noted your upbringing the fact
that you come from a law enforcement
family
yet despite that shared family
experience despite your record we've
heard claims that you are quote soft on
crime
these baseless charges are unfair
a conservative national review columnist
called claims brought by one of my
colleagues quote meritless to the point
of demagoguery
they fly in the face of pledges my
colleagues made that they would approach
your nomination with civility and
respect
and fact checkers including the
washington post abc news and cnm have
exposed some of these charges as
falsehoods critics have even stooped to
accusing you of sharing the views of the
clients you represented
even though they know that your work as
an attorney was in service to the bill
of rights and the constitution's promise
of effective assistance council
would law enforcement officials and
organizations including
the international association of chiefs
of police
the national organization of black law
enforcement executives and the fraternal
order of police have endorsed your
nomination if you were soft on crime of
course not
i'm confident the american people will
see through these attacks and any other
last-minute attempts to derail your
confirmation
in closing i want to share the words of
one more illinois and if you my if you
bear with me a brother famous one named
abraham lincoln
in august 1864
at the height of the civil war
president lincoln addressed the 166th
ohio regiment
lincoln said to the soldiers and i quote
i happen temporarily to occupy this big
white house
i am living witness that one of your
children may look to come here as my
father's child has
judge jackson we are all just temporary
occupants
of the senate the house even with a
lifetime appointment to the highest
court in the land
you judge jackson are one of mr
lincoln's living witnesses of an america
that is unafraid of challenge
willing to risk change
confident of the basic goodness of our
citizens
and your living witness to the fact that
in america all is possible
i now recognize my colleague and friend
the ranking member senator grassley
judge jackson
congratulations welcome to you and your
family
i thank you for taking time to visit
with me in my office after the president
nominated you
since president biden announced his
nominee for the supreme court
i've been encouraging my colleagues to
schedule meetings with you judge jackson
and they have come off
in addition i've continually emphasized
the need for a thorough
respectful
process
by the committee
now i want to talk a bit about
what everyone watching should expect
from this hearing
and what they shouldn't expect at the
hearing
we will conduct a thorough exhaustive
examination of judge jackson's record
and views
we won't try to turn this into a
spectacle based upon
alleged
process fouls
good news on that front
we're off to a very good start
unlike the start to the kavanagh
hearings
we
didn't have repeated choreographed
interruptions of chairman durbin during
his opening statements
like democrats interrupted me for more
than an hour during my opening statement
on the kavanaugh areas
what we will do however
is ask tough questions about judge
jackson's judicial philosophy
in any supreme court nomination
the most important thing that i look for
is the nominee's view of the law
judicial philosophy
and view on the role of a judge in our
constitutional system
i'll be looking to see whether judge
jackson is committed to the constitution
was originally understood
we all know there's a difference of
opinion
about the role judges should play
some of us believe the judges are
supposed to interpret the law as it was
understood when written
not make new law or simply fill in
vacuum
those of us who share that view
think that under our constitution
congress and not the federal courts
are given the authority to make law and
to set policy
now there are others who believe
that the courts should make policy they
believe in a so-called living
constitution
they think that the constitution's text
and structure don't limit what a judge
can do
to them deciding what the constitution
means is really a quote-unquote value
judgment
under that approach
judges can exercise their own
independent value judgments
one of the leading advocates for this
approach explained that as a judge you
quote reach the answer that essentially
your values tell you to reach end of
quote
in other words
those who subscribe to this philosophy
think that the founders really meant to
hide
elephants in mouse holes then
with a bit of creativity
these judges can always find that
elephant
that sounds like a good job description
instead
for legislators and not for judges
but for at least
four years democrats
systematically voted against many
well-credentialed nominees
that were diverse professionally
diverse geographically
diverse religiously
and rever uh
diverse ethnically
was it racist or anti-women for them to
do so
i don't believe that it was
democrats did it because the nominees
didn't agree with living
constitutionalism just as republicans
have opposed nominees based upon
their judicial philosophy
there are lots of problems with living
constitutionalism
in the senate
we spend a lot of time
writing legislation
we argue over the language
we negotiate over how broad or narrow
certain provisions of laws should be
if
we can't convince our colleagues to
adopt all of our ideas
we have been known to compromise every
once in a while
we depend on judges to interpret laws as
we write them if judges impose their own
policy preferences from the bench and
essentially revise the laws we pass
it makes it harder for us to write good
laws sometimes we need to include a
provision that's very broad to get a
colleague's support
if a judge rewrites the law later
because of vague notions about fairness
or equity or common good
that unravels all of our work here in
the congress more importantly
the american people should be able to
read the law
and know what it means
they shouldn't have to ask how a federal
judge who disagrees with the law could
reinterpret the words on that page
all of this leads
to the conclusion as to why
we must carefully examine federal judges
records especially supreme court
nominees
judge jackson has served as an assistant
public defender worked in private
practice and served on the united states
sentencing commission
she also served as a federal district
court judge from 2013 to 2021
she served on the dc circuit
since june last year
i'm sure senators will have a few
questions for judge jackson about the
two opinions she's authored since
joining the dc circuit as for a district
court record there have been some
accusations that we cherry-pick
some of judge jackson's criminal cases
well don't worry
we're going to talk about other cases as
well
i was disappointed that we weren't able
to get bipartisan agreement
to ask for judge jackson's documents
from her time as vice chair of the
sentencing commission the commission is
an independent agency created to advise
and assist congress and the executive
branch in the development of effective
and efficient
crime policy and that's a quote
unfortunately it sounds like we'll have
to wait until those documents are
required to be released and that will be
about 20 years from now
democrats
have argued for time
democrats have argued that
judge jackson's time on the commission
is an important part of her experience
that she'll draw on as a judge
the democrats are right on that point
that's why it would have been good to
see what our views were
as the head of
the commission
uh explained in a letter to senator
durbin the public doctrines turned over
to this committee represent the
consensus views of the commission and
not necessarily judge jackson's own
views the obama white house sent us
roughly
68 000 pages of material
but more than 38 000
of the 68 000 pages are repeated
copies
of emails threads that
keep the track
keeping track of the tweets about the
garland nomination
those emails contain just one tweet
about judge jackson
more than 13 000 of the 68 000 pages
are just lists of previous nominations
so that leaves only 16 000 of 68 000
that we received from the white house
that aren't obviously
useless like all the other documents
received but for comparison the white
house has still
withheld 48 000 pages under the
presidential
records
and foia exemptions now that's a lot of
hiding
but the limited number of useful records
that we received from the obama white
house show exactly why the sentencing
commission documents would have been
important
there are a number of dark money groups
on the left that argue federal judges
should make policy decisions based on
judges own values i've talked about the
troubling role of far left dark money
groups like demand justice have played
in this administration's judicial
selection process
when
the demand justice isn't creating short
lists for president biden to pick
judicial nominees from or putting out
new litmus tests they're running ads
campaign
campaigns attacking the independence of
the judiciary
they've strongly supported the so-called
progressive prosecutors who are soft on
violent crime in the face of rising
crime waves in cities like san francisco
philadelphia boston and new los angeles
now
what does that have to do with the
nominee before us
the obama white house records indicate
that a co-founder of the demand justice
played an important role in judge
jackson's nomination to the sentencing
commission and the district court the
demand justice co-founder even
interviewed judge jackson about the
nomination to the sentencing commission
commission it would be helpful
to know what demand justice co-founder
learned from that process and why they
strongly support judge jackson
however it isn't all been bad on the
document front i want to make clear
we'd ask for briefs that aren't
available online for dc circuit cases
judge jackson worked on as an attorney
at first we were told they might not be
available for a few weeks
to
but to our present surpr pleasant
surprise we received them early
apparently because the white house had
asked for the documents as well judging
by timetable
we were originally given to get the
breeze that request was made after she
was announced
now those documents
concern judge jackson's time as
assistant
federal public defender democrats have
accused republicans of vilifying
nominees who have represented criminal
defendants
that's
just not the case and i think that's a
very unfair accusation previously
supreme court nominees have also
represented criminal defendants on
appeals chief justice roger roberts was
appointed by supreme court to represent
a defendant in an important criminal
law case and he also helped represent an
invoice inmate in a florida
death row
and justice barrett represented a
criminal defendant appealing their
conviction while she was in private
practice now i've distinguished between
two types of nominees who have worked in
criminal cases there are bill of rights
attorneys who want to protect defendants
constitutional rights
then there are what i've called criminal
defense lawyers who disagree with our
criminal laws
they want to undermine laws that they
have policy disagreements with
and of course that's a very important
difference
just a year ago
no maybe it's now two years ago
democrats had no trouble opposing
nominees based on arguments these
nominees made on behalf of clients i can
read off quotes
of democrats doing that to trump
nominees but we only have
a few minutes for these opening
statements and i'd run out of time
on a final note
during
justice barrett's confirmation hearing
democrats said that she would
quote unquote judicial torpedo aiming at
protecting
protections for pre-existing conditions
we heard that argument repeatedly
conservatives and anyone who
actually looked at her record and laws
said that that was strictly nonsense
but democrats were sure otherwise
well when that case was finally decided
democrats were proven wrong
i'm sure that won't deter any of my
democratic colleagues for making some
confident predictions this time around
as well but the public record
should remember
their track record and perhaps take
those claims
were the grain of salt
they were wrong
in their strong declarations how justice
barrett would rule
judge jackson congratulations on your
nomination i look forward to hearing
from you about your record your views on
the law
and your judicial philosophy thank you
thank senator next is the president pro
tem of the senate and former chairman of
the committee patrick leahy
well thank you mr chair and i judge
jackson welcome it's it's really good to
see you again
you know uh today and actually
throughout this week the committee and
the country
are going to hear from
judge
jackson she's been nominated to be the
next associate justice
of the united states supreme court
any nomination any nomination the court
is historic
they've only been 115 justices in our
nation's history
judge jackson's nomination of course is
historic
in more ways than one
her nomination
pending a confirmation by the senate
will bring us one step closer to having
a supreme court that is more reflective
of our nation
when the diversity of race and gender
background education
and experience allow all americans
to look to their court
and see in its justices a reflection of
the american people
judge jackson you know with your
presence here today
you are writing a new page in the
history of america
a good page
who the president nominates and the
senate decides to confirm to our federal
judiciary and especially our nation's
highest court that's extremely important
the american people
our constituents
and their faith
and their faith in the courts
that's central to our democracy
they lose their faith the democracy
loses
the decisions made in our courts and
ultimately in the supreme court affect
the deadly lives of each one of us
fundamental questions about for example
access to health care
the integrity of our elections the
fairness of our criminal justice system
the preservation of bedrock
environmental laws
protections for workers
these issues
and many more are routinely decided by
the court
every american must believe that the
court is going to be impartial
they must believe that our courts are
not a mere political arm of the
executive or the congress but faithful
only to the rule of law
the stakes
and democracy are simply too high
let's make a few things clear
judge jackson is no
judicial activist
she is not a puppet of the so-called
radical left
she's been praised by republican
appointed
judges for jurisprudence
lawyers from the right and the left
who appeared before her in court have
called her judicious and even-handed
before as in the senate i tried a lot of
cases in
trial court and then courts of appeal
that's what i wanted somebody who was
judicious and even-handed i didn't care
what their politics were
judge jackson is not
anti-law enforcement
she hails from a law enforcement family
she's also won the support of preeminent
national law enforcement organizations
including the national paternal order of
police
no
she's not soft on crime
her background as a federal public
defender would bring informed
perspective of our criminal justice
system to the supreme court
i'm proud of being a former prosecutor
but confidence in my prosecution of a
case
was strongest when i knew the defendant
had the best possible representation
when both sides and the presiding judge
have a real grasp of her
criminal justice system
that's when justice is most likely to be
done so i would say that judge jackson's
background
is not a liability to the court
it's a much needed asset to the court
and since her nomination again here
today we've heard about the
long distinguished record of judge
jackson
graduate of harvard harvard law school
a judicial clerk at the district circuit
and supreme court
level a federal appellate judge a
federal district court judge a member
of the u.s sentencing commission an
attorney in private practice
and a federal public defender
what a resume all these experiences
and perspectives
have provided her a mastery of our
justice system
and that's in particular the criminal
justice system
if she is confirmed
she would become the first ever
justice
to have served as a federal public
defender
that's an important experience given how
much the court shapes our criminal
justice system
i say that from my experience as
a senator but also my experience
for nearly a decade as a prosecutor
and perhaps most of all it is judge
jackson's nearly 10 years
as an appellate and trial judge to
underscore the experience
she'd bring to the supreme court
she was confirmed unanimously by the
senate in 2013 to the d.c circuit court
she served with distinction for eight
years she issued more than 500 opinions
she presided over a dozen trials
and a bipartisan majority the senate
confirmed her to the dc circuit court of
appeals last year
let's be honest she's a fair and
impartial jurors
with a fidelity to the law above all
outs
that's what americans want to see in the
supreme court justice
years the so-called judicial wars have
left americans feeling like our courts
have become
increasingly partisan
the extreme interest of pressure groups
on both sides of the political spectrum
they've left the american people
wondering if they get a fair shake in
our courts
and yet in this moment we have reports a
unique opportunity to change that
narrative
i'm under no illusion
that we can mend this process overnight
but we have reports a nominee
which brought us together across party
lines before
and one i hope we can bring us back
together again
the senate can change course
return to how we fairly and objectively
evaluate nominees
we can do that with a highly qualified
nominee we have in judge jackson
now as chair durbin said
i'm the president pro tempore of the
senate
i'm a former chairman of this committee
i've participated in 20 prior supreme
court nomination processes
mostly into
confirmation a small handful not
in fact the first
justice i voted on votes from your state
senator durbin john paul stevens
i've supported nominees from both
democratic and republican presidents
and judge jackson i found a
distinguished nominee with an unless
record
that merits our respect regardless of
party
i believe the american people have seen
her what i've come to learn in my review
of her career and her life story
her nomination is reflection of the arc
of our democracy
the act of ben swore's justice as dr
king once said
although in fifth and sides with every
generation
we sought to become more inclusive more
representative
we've looked as citizens civic leaders
elected representatives
and yes to judges to strengthen our
democracy
and to recognize that our
strength comes from our diversity
judge jackson's story her nomination
today is part of the evolving story of
america
so judge jackson i want to congratulate
you on this nomination
despite all the darkness in the world
and the political
brinkstone shift has unfortunately
become a hallmark of congress in recent
years
your nomination actually fills me with
hope
hope for the court hope for the rule of
law hope for the country
one need looked no further
than the chaos the devastation
and the humanity in humanity halfway
around the world in ukraine
to know how precious our democracy is
and how precious the legacy we have in
our independent federal judiciary
i need look no further than my own
grandchildren
all of them
to know how necessary our fight for
freedom
fairness and equality is
the independence and impartiality of our
courts another supreme court
our cornerstone the great experiment
there's the united states and you the
american people have a nominee
in whom they can be proud we have before
as an historic moment and i hope we can
meet it as senators so i look forward to
your testimony thank you thank you
senator leahy next is another former
chair of the committee and senator from
south carolina lindsey graham
thank you mr chairman um
again congratulations uh well-deserved
honor here uh you have worked hard all
your life and
um you have much to be proud of
i have said
in the past and i think it's good for
the
court to look like america so count me
in on the idea of making the court more
diverse
and in the history of our country we've
never had an african-american woman
serve on the court
but i also said that didn't give much
coverage i want
i want i want the court
to play a particular role in america
one is make it more low like the country
but also make it operate in the
confines of the constitution that didn't
didn't get a lot of coverage um so the
hearings are going to be challenging
for you
informative for the public and
respectful by us
i hope we can meet that
those criteria um it won't be a circus
we're off to a good start
uh chairman grassley couldn't get first
word out of his mouth
before they shut down the place so
that's
off to a good start
most of us couldn't go back to our
offices during kavanaugh without getting
spit on hope that doesn't happen to you
all
i don't think it will
as to the historic nature of your
appointment i understand but when i get
lectured about this from my democratic
colleagues
i remember janice rogers brown the
african-american woman that was
filibustered by the same people praising
you
i remember
remember miguel estrada one of the
finest people ever met
completely wiped out
didn't make it through the
gang of uh 14 whatever gang i was in
i've been in so many i can't remember
he didn't make the cut
well-lived life just completely ruined
so if you're hispanic or
african-american conservative it's about
your philosophy
[Music]
now it's going to be about the historic
nature of the pick
it's going to be about your philosophy
the bottom line here is when it is about
philosophy when it's somebody of color
on our side
it's about we're all racist if we ask
hard questions it's not going to fly
with us we're used to it by now at least
i am
so it's not going to matter a bit to any
of us we're going to ask you what we
think you need to be asked and senator
hawley you need to ask her about her
record as a
district court judge you should i hope
you do and we'll see what she says very
fair game
uh now
president biden had a choice here
and he has every right to make it
elections have consequences he had many
qualified african-american women to
choose from he chose you
michelle chiles a district court judge
from south carolina supported by jim
clyburn that was in the mix i think it
came down to about two three four people
don't know for sure but that's what the
press was reporting
and uh when it came to judge
charles
this arabella group center white house
you talk about dark money you may be
onto something
uh this arabella group is funded by
source and some other liberal being
there they've got so many groups in
their group i can't name them all now
but they basically said if you if you
pick childs you may have a primary
opponent
the fl cio said justice judge child was
a union buster
the attacks from the left against judge
charles
was really pretty vicious to be honest
with you
so you say uh
judge jackson you don't have any
judicial philosophy per se
well somebody on the left believes you
do
or they wouldn't have spent the money
they spent to have you in this chair
so we're going to find out how that
statement
pulls up over time
a viewer's guide to this hearing
she will be asked about her sentencing
practices as a
district court judge and she'll have a
chance to explain her reasoning and you
can make up for yourself what this means
but it's good to be asked
uh about our legal views i'll ask her
about the law of armed conflict and her
view of the law of armed conflict the
fact that you represent the gitmo
detainees is not a problem with me
everybody deserves a lawyer you're doing
their country a great service when you
defend the most unpopular people but i
do want to know about your amicus briefs
after you're no longer a defense counsel
weighing into the supreme court about
how they decide law of war issues that
matters a lot to me
i think it does matter that the groups
that came to your aid at the expense of
judge childs how how did that happen and
why were they doing what they were doing
what is it about your nomination that
the most liberal people under the
umbrella
arabella threw in their money their time
their support and threatened uh joe
biden if he picked uh judge childs i
want to know more about that
i want to know about your judicial
philosophy
because people on the left the far
extreme
part of the left
believe that you were the best bet
and i want to know why they
reached that conclusion maybe there's
no explanation you can give us but let
we'll we'll talk about that
now when we say this is not kavanaugh
what do we mean
it means that democratic senators are
not going to have their windows busted
by groups that's what it means
it means that no republican senator
is going to unleash on you and attack
about your character when the hearing is
virtually over
none of us i hope have been sitting on
information about you as a person
for weeks or months
you come into our offices and we never
share it with you to allow you to give
your side the story we wait to the very
last minute when the hearing's about to
be gavel concluded and say oh by the way
i've got this letter
and so happened that every media outlet
in the country had the letter too so the
next morning there were headlines all
over the country really accusing judge
kavanaugh being basically bill cosby
none of us are going to do that to you
and if any of us does that to you
all hell will break out and it should
the media will uh be your biggest
cheerleader they're in your camp they
have every right to pick who they want
to pick
they won't be this constant attack
on you like judge cavanaugh and other
conservative judicial
appointments there won't be any
questioning of where you go to church
what kind of groups you're in in church
how you decide to raise your kids
what you believe in how you believe in
god
nobody's going to do that to you
and that's a good thing
so you're the beneficiary of a lot
you're the beneficiary of republican
nominees having their life turned upside
down
and it didn't work so i am hoping that
we can have a hearing that's respectful
that's informative that's challenging
and
president biden has every right to pick
who he'd like to pick that comes with
winning the white house
and i've been very inclined to support
the picks
of people that i would not have chosen
but this is a new game for the supreme
court
and this game is particularly disturbing
to me
because there's been a wholesale effort
of the left
to take down a nominee for my state
and i don't like it very much
and if that's the way the game's going
to be played then
i'll have a response
and i don't expect it to be
reward that way of playing the game
justice child judge childs would have
gotten 60 plus votes
there have been people in my caucus
that would have voted for her even
though we knew
should be a reliable liberal vote
because i and senator scott would have
stepped up
now we're picked now we're facing a
choice
sponsored by the most radical elements
of the democratic party when it comes to
how to be a judge
they have the most radical view
of what a judge should do
and you were their choice
and you'll be asked do you support
expanding the supreme court
i hope you give us an answer because it
shouldn't be hard either you do or you
don't
justice ginsburg said no she thought if
you just changed the number of the court
every time somebody knew came in power
it would ruin the court in the eyes of
the public and make it a joke over time
i agree with that
so i hope you can give us an answer to
that question
because i think the court
would be better off
if the judges stood up
for the court
if the judges told politicians
don't play this game with the court
because over time nobody wins
so congratulations
it's going to be a couple interesting
days
and we're off to a better start than we
have been in the past
and the one thing i can promise you you
will not be vilified you won't you will
not be attacked
for your religious views you will not be
accused of something that you could not
defend yourself against until it was too
late
thank you
thank you senator graham uh senator
feinstein
thanks very much mr chairman um
i want to begin by congratulating you
judge jackson on this appointment
um
i've reviewed the records of a number of
judicial nominees
during my service on this committee this
is actually the tenth set of
confirmation hearings for a supreme
court nominee that i've participated in
during my time in the senate and looking
at your record it's clear that you have
the qualifications
and the experience and the knowledge
needed to serve on the supreme court and
as a woman it makes me very proud of
that
as we begin these hearings we as
senators take seriously our
constitutional duty to advise the
president on his appointment of a new
supreme court justice
in the current term alone the supreme
court is addressing cases on issues that
are foundational to who we are as a
country let me just give you three
examples
the court is considering a woman's
fundamental right to control her own
body and make her own health care
decisions
it is considering the legal authority of
the environmental protection agency to
fight climate change and it's
considering whether states have the
power to enact common sense gun safety
protections
as a former mayor i saw how these
officials how these problems
affect people everyday people on
everyday streets
throughout my city and then subsequently
the state of california
this is not your first time at this in
fact it's your fourth time in front of
this committee
the full senate has already confirmed
you on a bipartisan basis three times
to serve as vice chair of the u.s
sentencing commission in 2010 as a
federal district court judge
2013 and as a federal appellate court
judge in 2021
and you have done us proud
each of the three times the senate has
considered your record
your experience and your ability
senators on both sides of the aisle have
determined that you have the
qualifications
and the temperament it takes to uphold
the values
of our judicial branch
as i see it
those values are knowledge
even-handedness
impartiality
integrity respect for the rule of law
and fundamental fairness to all
and your record
actually shows that you exemplify these
values the supreme court is not a
political institution
rather the court stands above politics
and above partisanship
and we look to federal judges to be
independent and unbiased
judge jackson in reviewing your record
one thing in particular stands out to me
and that's your commitment to uphold
justice under the law
this is one of the ultimate
responsibilities
of the supreme court and your record
suggests to me
that you understand the weight of that
responsibility
you've had several mentors early in your
career
who unders who i understand were
important in instilling these values
in you as a young lawyer
one of these those mentors were justice
stephen breyer
who you served as a law clerk and to
whose seat on the supreme court you have
now been nominated what a treat for you
to see that happen and i know for him as
well justice breyer has been a
thoughtful and even-handed judge
throughout his career
so you have learned from the best
and you have brought those lessons
and that dedication to equal justice
with you throughout your career in the
law
you have strong credentials you're a
graduate of both harvard university and
harvard law school
a former supreme court clerk
and you have served as a federal judge
for nine years
most recently on the u.s court of
appeals for the district circuit
these are impressive credentials and
they are also familiar to those of us
who have received excuse me who have
reviewed numerous nominees to the court
but you also bring experiences that are
less common especially at the supreme
court
the first is your service as a federal
public defender earlier in your career
if you were confirmed you would be the
first ever federal public defender to
sit on the court
and the first justice since thurgood
marshall
with significant experience representing
low-income defendants and criminal cases
i believe this is very significant and
important
because as a former public defender you
understand the power of our
constitutional rights
including the sixth amendment
right to counsel and the fifth amendment
right to due process
you also understand the effect of law
and the law enforcement system on the
most vulnerable and i believe your eight
years of expertise as a trial judge on
the d.c district court is very valuable
so
if confirmed you would be one of only
two former federal district court judges
serving on the court the other being
justice sotomayor
i believe your perspective
as a former trial judge will serve you
well on the court
you've been responsible for implementing
the precedent set by higher courts and
because of that you understand the need
for clarity in legal opinions
for achieving consensus wherever
consensus is possible and that has been
your record
it's important to have justices with a
broad set of views and experiences on
the supreme court and i believe your
background and your experience will only
serve to strengthen the supreme court
i trust that my colleagues on this
committee will recognize that you are
unquestionably qualified for this
position i wish you well i look forward
to learning more about you over the
course of the coming days thank you mr
chairman thanks senator feinstein
senator cornyn of texas
thank you mr chairman uh judge jackson
let me join my colleagues in extending a
warm welcome to you and your family
congratulations on your nomination
i enjoyed sitting down with you recently
and talking about your experience as
both a lawyer and a judge and how that's
molded your views of our judicial system
in the coming days i hope we can have a
candid conversation
about your record and your judicial
philosophy
as i told you other the other day these
proceedings will be thorough
but civil
as a member of this committee i've had
the opportunity to provide advice and
consent on seven previous supreme court
nominations this is number eight
i've seen the good
the bad
and the ugly
when it comes to the way the senate
conducts these proceedings and so has
the american people
one of the best things i think comes
from this
process is uh i think this is a
teachable moment
that will remind all of us about the
wisdom of the
founders who wrote a constitution
that made sure that our rights would be
fixed and certain
so that these rights whether they are
the right to keep and bear arms or
the right to practice one's faith would
be preserved from generation to
generation
as you know the founders established
three separate branches of our
government
a system of checks and balances if you
will this was done for the purpose of
preserving individual freedom and
avoiding tyranny
and ensure that our government was
ultimately accountable to the people
from whom all political power
derives article 3 as you know vests the
supreme court and inferior courts with
the judicial power
but the framers were very clear
the courts are not vested with a policy
making authority
according to our constitution courts
hear cases
and controversies and decide them
nothing more
nothing less
that's an important distinction to
remember in the days that lie ahead
indeed the framers envisioned that the
courts would be would have a modest but
very important role in our three
branches of government
you'll recall federalist 78 where
alexander hamilton said the courts would
have no influence over either the sword
or the purse
and that
it may truly be said
to have neither force nor will
but merely judgment
part of that judgment requires a judge
to go where the law commands whether or
not you personally approve or not
and it starts with deciding cases as
presented and not cherry picking the
facts or the law
and starting with the decision and then
justifying it by the way
by
cherry pick facts and
provisions of the law
while this famers provided that the
president would nominate
judges
the framers also set up a framework that
allowed judges once you are confirmed to
exercise independent judgment free from
elections
and politics and so these supreme court
confirmation hearings are really the
only chance we have
as representatives of the people to vet
somebody who will serve the remainder of
their life
unfortunately there are some driven by
their ideology that want the supreme
court to do more than what i've just
described
these are some of the same people who
tried to bully justice breyer into an
early retirement
these activists demand that the court
make policy and deliver results
they can't achieve through the
deliberation compromise and rough and
tumble of legislative politics
and when the court does not deliver the
results they want
they attack its institutional integrity
and legitimacy
in recent years these radical views have
made their way into the mainstream
on the campaign trail president biden
refused to disavow court packing two
years ago the democratic leader of the
senate went to the supreme court steps
and threatened two sitting supreme court
justices by name if they did not rule in
a particular way
dark money groups like demand justice
have paid millions of dollars to promote
promote court packing and so public
distrust in the legitimacy of the
supreme court
justice breyer as you know
recently warned of the crippling effect
this politicalization of the court and
its decision-making can have
he said without the public's trust the
court would no longer be able to act as
a check on the other branches of
government
and a guarantee guarantor of the rule of
law threatening the foundations of our
constitutional system
judge i know you know that the courts
are not designed to deliver particular
policy outcomes or to invent new rights
out of whole cloth
that's why it's imperative that we
explore your judicial philosophy during
this hearing
i will say i was a bit troubled when you
that you have not so far provided us
with much clarity
on that matter
someone as accomplished as you are
who spent years engaging and thinking
about our constitution and laws has
surely formed a judicial philosophy
this is not your first rodeo
you've had an impressive career judge
as a supreme court clerk a pellet
advocate and trial court judge
i like the fact that you've had such
broad experience in our judicial and
legal system
but there are still unanswered questions
that remain
i'm a bit troubled by some of the
positions you've taken and arguments
that you've made
representing people who have committed
terrorist acts against the united states
and other dangerous criminals
as someone who has deep respect for the
adversarial system of justice i
understand
the importance of zealous advocacy but
it appears that sometimes this zealous
advocacy has gone beyond the pale
and in some instances it appears that
your advocacy has bled over
into your decision-making process as a
judge
you've had some cases reversed like all
judges do
but some of them were particularly high
profile when you ruled against a
republican administration
i'm eager to understand why in some
instances you found that you could not
decide a particular issue while in other
instances you enjoined a republican
administration from implementing its
policies
i'm also interested as others have
mentioned
in your opinion why pro-abortion dark
money groups like demand justice and
anti-religious liberty groups are
pouring millions of dollars into a
public campaign in support of your
nomination
jackson these are some of the questions
and concerns i have
i assure you that you will have every
opportunity to address these concerns as
the committee evaluates your ability to
fairly and impartially deliver justice
should you be confirmed
so i welcome your
testimony at these hearings and i look
forward to our
give and take thank you very much thanks
senator cornyn senator white house rhode
island
thank you very much chairman welcome
judge jackson i could not be
more delighted to have you here
this is a refreshing moment
we are holding a hearing for an
accomplished
experienced
highly qualified
nominee to the supreme court
who came to us
not through a dark money-funded
turnstile
but through a fair
and honest selection process
judge jackson has unparalleled breadth
of experience both on and off the bench
she has already been confirmed by the
senate
three times
she serves on what is often called the
second highest court in the land
the dc circuit handles some of the most
difficult and consequential cases in the
nation
often taking up questions that later
come before
the supreme court
judge jackson that will enable you to
jump right in
once confirmed
before the dc circuit judge jackson was
a trial judge in the district court in
the district of columbia
ruling on hundreds of cases and
presiding over trials including many
jury trials
judge jackson you have presided over
virtually every kind of case
a federal trial judge can hear across
criminal and civil law
you have more experience
actually trying cases in your courtroom
than any other member of the court
as a member of the u.s sentencing
commission you helped establish the
policies and practices for federal
courts
when deciding criminal punishments
with commissioners from both parties
you helped implement our bipartisan fair
sentencing act
complicated
and consequential work
and we thank you
it matters to me mr chairman that judge
jackson was also a civil litigator and
public defender
she wasn't groomed
in partisan petri dishes
she learned practical
courtroom experience in both civil and
criminal law
how the judicial system works
and how it serves or doesn't serve
different litigants
and i must say that in rhode island we
love
that before you clerked for justice
stephen breyer
you clerked for rhode islander bruce
celia
on the first circuit
judge celia was nominated by ronald
reagan
he is well regarded
by bench
and barr
and he thinks the world
of judge jackson
she is absolutely everything you would
want in a supreme court justice
he told the boston globe in february she
has all the tickets
in terms of her intelligence
her education
her work experience
and her demonstrated
judicial temperament
he actually said that waiting for the
supreme court selection process to take
place
made him feel like a father
waiting to hear his daughter's
college admissions results
we very much appreciate that
rhode island attached to this nomination
judge jackson is steadfastly committed
to the constitution and the rule of law
and her record reflects
the type of even-handedness and
independence
that will make her such a good
supreme court justice
her guiding principle she has said is to
consistently apply
the same level of analytical rigor to a
case
no matter who
or what is involved in the legal action
she says this means you can
quoting again be consistent
in the way you are analyzing the issues
and you can set aside any thoughts about
who is making the arguments
and what advantages any side might take
away from your opinions
if you have fidelity to the rule of law
that is grounded in looking at only
those inputs
she said then
i think you can rule
without fear or favor
mr chairman judge jackson will be an
exemplary justice both because of the
qualities
that she possesses
and because she did not undergo
a secret pre-selection process to get
here
she is before us on the basis of her own
merit
not on the recommendation of a secretive
right-wing donor operation
hiding behind anonymous multi-million
dollar donations
and aimed at capturing the united states
supreme court as if it were some 19th
century railroad commission
the unpleasant fact is that the present
court is the court that dark money built
anonymous donations funded the
federalist society
while it housed the selection turnstile
run by the dark money donors
anonymous money funded the dark money
group
down the same hallway as the federalist
society that ran the dark money
political campaigns for the selected
justices
and because of all that secrecy
americans are denied any real
understanding of the overlap of all that
dark money
with the political dark money funding
the republican party
which could well explain the wreckage of
senate norms rules and procedures
that accompanied the confirmation
process
of recent nominees
judge jackson's nomination and the
process by which she was selected
stand in sharp contrast
president biden took a thorough and
independent review of her record
and she will proceed through a thorough
and fair process here in the senate
we will abide by the new precedents set
by republicans in recent years
but we will not be fabricating new ones
we've already seen dark money groups
dark money
to run ads
charging the dark money swayed this
selection
we are hearing that again today
ironic
when hundreds of millions of dollars in
right-wing dark money
built
the current
court majority
and still signals its wishes through
flotillas
of dark money front groups posing as
amicu curie
i welcome the debate on these points
and i look forward to hearing more from
the excellent nominee before us
judge celia
counted the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg an old friend
i see some of the same qualities in
katanji that i saw in ruth he said
humility
the ability to inspire others in a quiet
way not at the top of her voice
some people he said
have the capacity to inspire by example
and the force of their reason
judge jackson i'm certain
your capacity to inspire through force
of reason will be on display here this
week
thank you chairman durbin for your
leadership of the hearing and thank you
judge jackson for being with us today
thanks senator whitehouse senator lee of
utah
thank you mr chairman and thank you
judge jackson for joining us today i
appreciated the conversation you and i
had in my office a few days ago
and your willingness to uh engage in a
lively interesting conversation during
that we'll look forward to more of that
this week i've enjoyed uh also meeting
your husband and your two
lovely daughters uh they're wonderful
people i'm grateful to you for your
service um
your service to the federal judiciary
and as a member of the bar
um
you bring to the court as i mentioned to
you last week
um a unique set of uh
of experiences if you're confirmed you
will
be someone who has served at all three
levels of the federal judiciary
and
as a result of that you'll have a
perspective that's different and that of
most who have served on that court
during the modern era
and uh i appreciate your willingness to
be considered and to be here to talk
to us about our questions
i echo what uh many of my colleagues
have said today in that i am dedicated
as i always have been
to making sure that these
hearings are respectful uh
engaging in the politics of personal
destruction is not something we should
ever aspire to it is something that has
occurred
uh on this committee in the context of
supreme court nominations i'm pleased to
say that it has never been under
republican leadership that such attacks
have occurred and i intend to make sure
that this hearing
is no exception to that there are a few
reasons for that
first and foremost the most obvious is
that
respect to human beings requires it
secondly it's important because
if we focus on personal attacks that
means we will
be betraying our duty under the
constitution and to our constituents to
make sure that we do our jobs fairly
and properly
when we're focused on things that we
have no business doing like bringing
forward
spurious last-minute uncorroborated
accusations of our personal nature
we neglect the importance of talking
about
the jurisprudential role the the
philosophy that guides individual
jurists
and they
document that we're all sworn to uphold
and protect the constitution of the
united states
it's also important for an additional
reason a third reason
that has to do with the fact that
having been nominated to this position
we know that you stand a a very decent
likelihood of ultimately being confirmed
to this position
in which case you'll serve as a member
of the supreme court of the united
states and i think it's important
that even when especially when we
disagree with decisions issued by that
tribunal
we as it
as a committee as the senate judiciary
committee
not engage in speech or behavior that
would undermine the
legitimacy of the supreme court of the
united states you see it's the
legitimacy of the courts that gives them
their potence their their power their
significance in our system of government
we all have a duty to make sure that we
don't undermine that very thing that we
purport to be protecting
let me tell you some of the things that
i look for
uh when reviewing a nominee and a few
things that i intend
to focus on in these hearings with you
one of them uh
will involve uh any nominee's commitment
to judicial self-restraint to
understanding the judicial role what it
is and what it is not
any judicial nominee these days
will acknowledge that he or she
understands that the role of the judge
is to interpret the law based on what it
says
rather than on the basis of the judge's
personal opinion
this is all very true
it raises questions as to how exactly
that goes about and what steps
what tools
what rhetorical
linguistic devices the the jurist in
question might follow in order to do
that i'm looking for someone
who
is ideally
going to echo something that uh justice
amy coney barrett said in her
confirmation proceedings in which she
likened the constitution
this document uh written by wise men
nearly two and a half centuries ago
uh wise men who i believe were raised up
by almighty god to that very purpose
to the extent we followed that document
it's helped foster the development of
the greatest civilization
the world has ever known
but she she likened this uh and our
commitment to it as a little
like what odysseus
told his crew she said the constitution
is like how odysseus ties himself to the
mast to resist the song of the sirens
she then goes on to to explain that uh
he told the crew do not untie me no
matter how much i beg or plead don't
untie me from the mast
he wanted to avoid the tempting call of
the sirens
attempting to call the sirens is
inherent it's
in government itself it's it's
understandable
and that's why
we tie ourselves to it critical to that
is the federal judiciary
the ultimate backstop the the backstop
that's there to resolve disputes
now
the constitution isn't just something
for the courts it's not something that's
owned uh
exclusively and independently by the
federal judiciary or the supreme court
itself but it does play an important
role because the court's there to
resolve disputes
that arise within the court's
jurisdiction
uh as to the meaning of a particular
provision of federal law whether in the
constitution itself or as enacted into
law by congress
so we need
a jurist who's willing to to respect
that role
and demonstrate judicial humility what i
mean by that is
an ability to acknowledge that
there are
a lot of things not within the province
of the courts that entail policy
that
the job of the court
of
the judiciary is never to exert will or
force
it is only judgment it's discerning what
the law says
a nominee also i believe needs to show
a steadfast commitment to the principle
of separation of powers
there are a
couple of forms of separation of powers
required by the constitution
uh
along two axes one operates along the
vertical axis we call federalism it says
most of the power
of government within the united states
most powers
that government might exercise are to be
exercised at the state and local level
power that's federal is the exception
not the norm in our constitutional
system of government
the other form of separation of powers
operates along the horizontal axis
it's one that recognizes within the
federal government which is limited
we're gonna have one branch our branch
congress that makes the laws
another branch headed by the president
the executive branch that enforces the
and the third branch which interprets
them resolving disputes between
parties coming before the court's
jurisdiction
third
i think it's important that
a jurist within our system of government
acknowledge the importance of
interpreting the law
as it was written as it was understood
by the public at the time of its
enactment if a statute
or if uh provision of the constitution
at the time of its ratification
this is part of how we tie ourselves to
the mast
making sure that we
undertake efforts to make sure that
we're interpreting it uh based on how
the public understood those words
regardless of the subjective intent of
any particular lawmaker or group thereof
the public meaning at the time it became
law
this is how we maintain the rule of law
this is part of how we've
we've uh given force to this uh greatest
civilization that human history has ever
recorded
it's through the rule of law and tying
ourselves to that mass
there are increasing threats
to this
we've seen those threats arise with
efforts to de-legitimize the court and i
i'm
sickened every time i see or hear or
experience one of those efforts to
delegitimize it
we've heard some today in in fact
uh comments that i think by their very
nature delegitimize the court another
thing that can delegitimize the court
are arguments made in favor of packing
the supreme court
this was attempted by president franklin
d roosevelt in 1937 it did lasting
damage to the court it didn't succeed as
a legislative matter
but it's arguable that it left a mark
and not a pretty one
there is nothing in the constitution
that requires us to have nine and only
nine justices that is uh under the
constitution left to congress's
determination
but nine is a number that works it's
worked now for uh 152 years it's not one
that we ought to revisit and it's one
that
um supreme court justices of various
ideologies
including your former boss uh justice
breyer uh whom i
really enjoyed getting to know uh when
serving as a law clerk on the supreme
court enjoyed our conversations with him
uh he justice ginsburg justice thomas
and so many others have been against
that we must protect the court we may
not
protect the court we lose ability to
protect the court if we allow arguments
to take root that are focused on
expanding that and turning the court
into a political body thank you mr
chairman thanks senator lee senator
klobuchar of minnesota thank you very
much
chairman durbin and thank you ranking
member grassley judge jackson welcome uh
we met recently in my office and we have
seen you in this committee before and we
are so happy to have you back
uh if senator whitehouse is pleased that
you once clerked for a rhode island
judge we in minnesota are equally happy
that you are wearing bold purple today
winning over both prince and minnesota
vikings fans the world over
i'd like to welcome your husband patrick
and your two daughters and your other
family members and friends
it is clear that your family starting
with your parents who i got to meet who
are sitting there uh in the front row uh
who once worked as teachers that your
family has been a constant source of
inspiration and support for you
my mom taught second grade until she was
70 years old
so i know first hand it's pretty great
to have a parent who was also a teacher
and they never stop checking your
spelling
as a lawyer who also balanced work with
parenthood myself i particularly enjoyed
your story judge about sitting with your
dad you had a coloring book and he was
studying his law books
while these hearings are truly an
opportunity as my colleagues have
pointed out for americans to get to know
your legal acumen
we also learn about your background your
experiences your values and for so many
of us including people watching this
hearing across the country our values
start with our family
there's something else particularly
special about this hearing of course
you've been nominated by president biden
as the first black woman to serve on the
supreme court
that's historic with
115 justices having served so far in our
history you're the first black woman and
it's long past time
in fact this entire hearing is about
opening things up the hearing room we've
opened it up with actual guests
for the first time in a while
and you're opening up the senate and the
court by virtue of your very presence
you judge are opening a door that's long
been shut to so many and by virtue of
your strong presence your skills your
experience you are showing so many
little girls and little boys across the
country that anything and everything is
possible
we're here to carry out one of this
committee's most solemn constitutional
obligations to advising biden's
nomination to the supreme court but this
is also a time for us to consider the
supreme court's place in our democracy
and how it impacts people
you've been nominated to justice briar's
seat
you clerked for him and i know he's been
and is a wonderful mentor to you
so i'd like to start with some of his
words justice breyer once wrote that the
supreme court
must help maintain public acceptance of
its own legitimacy
he said
it can do this best by helping ensure
that the constitution remains workable
in a broad sense of the term
specifically it can and should interpret
the constitution in a way that works for
the people of today
making it work for the people of today
those words his words are highly
relevant to the court
and justice breyer didn't just write
about those values in his 27 years on
the court he lived them he approached
cases with a pragmatic view of the law
and he understood that reference to the
constitution requires not just a respect
for the past although it does that
but also an eye toward the future
as we are here to confirm a new justice
for his seat i urge my colleagues to
remember his words about how the court
must consider the effect of its actions
on people's lives how it must be able to
see the real people at the other end of
its rulings like americans who are one
supreme court decision away from losing
their health insurance or one court
decision away from the ability to make
their own health care choices
or the dreamers who could lose the only
country they've ever known or the people
who waited for hours in the rain one
recent election day in wisconsin wearing
garbage bags and homemade mass in the
middle of what would soon become a
global pandemic just to cast a ballot
just to exercise their constitutional
right to vote
the court decides cases with
life-changing consequences for people it
makes decisions that dictate health and
safety standards for workers protections
for seniors whether we can have clean
air and clean water the supreme court
issues rulings that can determine who
can make their voices heard in our
democracy and how they can do it
so judge jackson this week i look
forward to hearing more on your views
about the real world implications of the
law
and about how you will respect the
constitution and legal precedent
all the while striving to ensure we have
a court that works for the american
people
judge i believe you have exactly the
sort of understanding of what the law
means in people's lives that americans
would want in a justice you're from a
family that knows something about making
it work
both of your parents attended segregated
primary schools and later became
teachers and when your dad set his
sights on becoming a lawyer your mom
figured out how to support the family
while he attended law school
after being a star debater in high
school you went on to graduate magna [ __ ]
laude in college and went on to graduate
with honors from law school after law
school you clerked for federal judges
nominated by both democratic and
republican presidents and of course you
had the honor of serving as a clerk to
justice breyer these aren't just lines
on your resume they show that you have
worked to apply the law at every level
of the federal system and beyond those
credentials you have the perspectives of
someone who has seen the law through the
eyes of those closest to it your brother
worked as a police officer in baltimore
one of your uncles was a detective and
another was the chief of police of the
city of miami you know what it means for
a person to put their life on the line
to defend the rule of law it is no
surprise to me that you received the
letter that senator durbin mentioned the
letter of support from the fraternal
order of police and as a former federal
public defender you also understand that
for a justice system to be truly
workable it must account for those who
lack the resources to defend themselves
and you would be the first justice to
bring that experience to the court
judge i believe it is because of your
experience and respect for the law that
the senate has confirmed you three times
with bipartisan support as vice chair
and commissioner of the u.s sentencing
commission judge on the d.c district
court and most recently the d.c circuit
court of appeals in each of these roles
you've lived up to that bipartisan
support as a commissioner over 90
percent of the votes you participated in
were either unanimous or voice votes as
a district court judge you wrote nearly
600 opinions applying the law and
precedent to the facts fairly and
impartially without regard to your
personal views i will note that if you
are confirmed you will join justice
sotomayor as the only other justice on
the bench with experience as a trial
court judge as a circuit court judge you
have written decisions joined by judges
appointed by presidents of both parties
and let's not forget you have nine years
of judicial experience more than four
other justices currently on the court
prior to their confirmations not that
we're counting
judge jackson and i expect this to come
through loud and clear during these
hearings you have the experience and
record of a jurist who is dedicated to
the fair application of the law
committed to consensus and determined to
make sure that the court and the
constitution work for the people of
today
and one last point
judge your confirmation your
confirmation hearing comes at a moment
in our history when the people of this
country are once again seeing this time
in ukraine that democracy can never be
taken for granted
eternal vigilance it's been said
is the price of liberty last week i was
at the ukrainian polish border with
refugees streaming through checkpoints
leaving everything they had behind with
only a suitcase and a backpack walking
into the loving arms of their neighbors
in poland a country with a long hard
history of having been invaded by nazis
and russians and prussians and habsburgs
as our ambassador there told me at this
moment in history the people of poland
are achieving the dreams their
grandparents could never realize they
are saying to their ukrainian neighbors
we value freedom and respect your
democracy we value you so much that we
will take you into our homes and into
our hearts we will open our doors and
not shut you out
and this horrendous war against evil and
the courage of the ukrainian people is
happening at the very same time our
country is opening our minds
after being separated through a two-year
pandemic from our neighbors not only
around the world but in our own country
in our own towns
this moment bestowed upon us a new
opportunity to see one another again and
to be part of our own democracy to
respect each other's rights and views to
see that we are not a nation of 300 plus
million silos
instead we are a nation that must
re-embrace the simple principle that
unites us as americans and that is that
our country is so much bigger in what
unites us than what divides us
that's the pivotal moment we are in
that's your moment it's a time for us to
consider what the courts mean to our
democracy to recall how the
framers envisioned the courts to work as
a ballast in our system of government
and to rededicate ourselves to the
sacred protection of our rights and the
upholding of our constitution so as we
move forward with these hearings let us
be grounded in the central role of the
court and the constitution in our
democracy of what it means to our system
of government that we can never take for
granted and how we must always be
vigilant that it is serving the people
judge jackson i'm confident you will
come to the bench as a justice with a
bedrock appreciation of what the
constitution and the law means to
america with the real world perspective
we need thank you for your willingness
to serve at this important time
thank senator klobuchar senator cruz of
texas
thank you mr chairman
judge jackson congratulations on your
nomination
eleven thousand one hundred and seven
men and women have served as members of
the house of representatives
one thousand nine hundred and ninety
four men and women have served as
members of the united states senate
only 115 men and women have served as
supreme court justices
the position to which you have been
nominated
is extraordinarily important
and that is why the senate is given the
responsibility for advice and consent
under the constitution
because the job matters immensely
supreme court confirmations were not
always controversial in fact bushrod
washington when nominated to the supreme
court in 1798 was confirmed the very
next day
so what changed
well what changed is starting in the
1960s and 1970s the supreme court's role
in our society changed dramatically
the supreme court became a policy-making
body rather than a merely judicial body
just a moment ago my colleague senator
klobuchar said we should consider the
supreme court's place in our democracy
starting in the 60s and 70s the supreme
court decided its place in our democracy
at least too many justices
was to set aside the democratic
decisions of the people
and instead to mandate the policy
outcomes they themselves supported
our democratic colleagues want the
supreme court
to be anti-democratic
our democratic colleagues get frustrated
with the democratic process
when they can't pass gun control laws
because the american people don't
support them they want unelected judges
to mandate those same laws instead
law after law after law that they can't
get through the democratic process the
democrats have decided it's much simpler
to convince five lawyers in black robes
than to try to convince 330 million
americans
that is why supreme court confirmation
hearings have become so contentious is
because the supreme court is irrigated
to itself a responsibility the
constitution doesn't give it
which is to make contested policy
decisions and take them away from the
american people
now what should this hearing be and what
should it not be well you've heard a
number of members on the republican side
of the aisle quite clear on what it
should not be this will not be a
political circus
this will not be the kind of character
smear
sadly our democratic colleagues have
gotten very good at
and it's important to note you know a
couple of years ago i was doing
my weekly podcast and i was on with a
noted liberal intellectual
who made a comment something to the
effect of well both sides do this both
sides smear supreme court justices
and i was forced to laugh out loud and
say look i understand that's a pretty
good talking point
it just happens not to be true
it is only one side of the aisle the
democratic isle
that went so into the gutter
with judge robert bork
that they invented a new verb to bork
someone
it is only one side of the aisle that
with justice clarence thomas
was so reprehensible
that is the president who nominated him
president george herbert walker bush
wrote at the time quote what's happening
to clarence thomas is just plain
horrible all the groups that tried to
beat him up on abortion or affirmative
action have now come out of the woodwork
they are trying to destroy a decent man
this is an ugly process and one can see
clearly
why so many good people elect to stay
out of public life
as justice thomas observed in that
hearing
what happened there was to use his words
a high-tech lynching
and i would note the chairman who
presided over that disgrace
was joe biden
and then most of the members of this
committee remember the confirmation
hearing of brett kavanaugh
one of the lowest moments in the history
of this committee
where democrats on this committee sat on
allegations didn't refer them to the fbi
didn't ask for investigations hid them
and then leaked them
against the wishes
of the complainant
and we began
a circus that featured spartacus moments
featured such nuts
as michael avenatti
whom cnn breathlessly for some months
described as a possible democratic
presidential candidate that's before
presumably he became a felon in recent
months
judge jackson i can assure you
that your hearing will feature none of
that disgraceful behavior
no one is going to inquire into your
teenage dating habits
no one is going to ask you with mock
severity do you like beer
but that's not to say this hearing
should be
non-substantive
and
non-vigorous
in this hearing this committee has a
responsibility to focus on issues to
focus on your record to focus on
substance
to do our very best to ascertain what
kind of justice you would be
and a couple of
straw men
it is no longer the case that supreme
court confirmation hearings are merely
about qualifications
there are some who say well if the
justice is qualified the senate should
confirm there was a time that was the
case
our democratic colleagues have abandoned
that standard long ago
our democratic colleagues
then senator joe biden was perfectly
happy to vote against john roberts
someone who was unquestionably qualified
for the court he was perfectly happy to
vote against sam alito someone who was
unquestionably qualified for the court
and indeed
every member of our democratic
colleagues who was here at the time
participated in the first ever
filibuster of a supreme court justice on
partisan lines with justice neil gorsuch
they did so for someone unquestionably
qualified
but they had a political agenda and so
every one of them happily
filibustered justice gorsuch gorsuch
likewise it's not about race
we will see democrats in the media
suggest that any senator that
is skeptical of your nomination that
questions you vigorously or that dares
to vote against you must somehow
harbor racial animus
if that were the standard
i would note we are sitting on a
committee where multiple members of this
committee the senior democrats in the
committee happily filibustered judge
janice rogers brown
a very qualified african-american woman
nominated the d.c circuit
and they did so precisely because they
wanted to prevent
judge brown
from becoming justice brown the first
african-american women joe biden was
among the democrats filibustering
the first african-american woman
nominated the d.c circuit
the senior democrats on this committee
also filibustered miguel estrada
as the staff for senator ted kennedy
said in writing at the time
the democrats filibustered miguel
estrada quote
because he is hispanic
they were explicitly racial
if you dare
if you are hispanic or african-american
and you dare depart
from their political orthodoxy they will
crush you they will attack you they will
slander you they will filibuster you
so this is not about race
it is however about issues and substance
and i got to say i agree with chairman
durbin
chairman dermot quoted paul simon and he
said
history will judge quote
did she restrict freedom
or did she expand it
i agree with that
the reason the american people care
about the supreme court is it is
integral to protecting or taking away
our constitutional rights
when it comes to free speech
this committee should inquire will you
protect the rights of americans to speak
to say unpopular ideas to say ideas that
the government doesn't want you to say
that you nonetheless have a right to say
will you protect freedom or restrict it
when it comes to religious liberty
will a justice vote to protect your
right to live according to your faith
and according to your conscience
or will a justice vote to crush
religious liberty and strip those rights
away
the second amendment
will a justice vote to defend your
second amendment rights to keep and bear
arms to defend your family to defend
your children
or will justice roll over to the
democrats
that want a disarmed citizenry
the right to life
will a justice protect the rights of the
people the rights of state legislatures
to enact laws protecting innocent life
protecting unborn life
stopping abominations like partial birth
abortion
or will a justice view her job
as a super legislator
striking down all such rights
school choice
will a justice protect the rights of
kids to get a quality education or will
a justice legislate from the bench and
shut down school choice programs across
this country and crime
we are seeing murder rates carjacking
rates crime rates skyrocketing across
the country
in significant part because political
soros back district attorneys because of
democratic efforts to abolish the police
and part of the democratic effort to
abolish the police is nominating
justices that consistently side with
violent criminals release violent
criminals refuse to enforce the law and
that results in jeopardizing innocent
citizens
so all of those questions are fair game
will you follow the law what does your
record indicate will you protect the
rights of every american citizen
regardless of race regardless of party
regardless of views
that's what the focus of this hearing
should be
thank you senator senator coons from
delaware
and thank you chairman durbin ranking
member grassley
judge jackson
congratulations on your nomination it is
a joy and a blessing to welcome you and
your family and your supporters here
this morning
as both senators klobuchar and cruz have
laid out in great and forceful detail
the decisions of the united states
supreme court have daily impact regular
bearing on the lived experience of
americans and that is in part why
hearings for this important role are so
contentious
i have been looking forward to this day
since president biden announced your
nomination in february and over the next
several days members of this committee
will have the privilege of helping
introduce you to the american people so
that they can
gain the sense of confidence that i have
in your values your skills your
competence
and the necessity of confirming you to
the supreme court
we'll be inviting you to speak directly
to the american public and share the
lived experiences
the strong qualifications the judicial
temperament and the strength of
character that made you not only an
historic nominee to the supreme court
but an outstanding one as well
i want to acknowledge up front that
president biden selected you to fill the
seat on the court being vacated by
justice breyer a justice whom i admire
and in the work he's done as a jurist
over decades has shown us a model of a
supreme court justice in his 42 years on
the federal bench 30 years on the
supreme court he's lived up to the
highest ideals of american jurisprudence
he has served with wisdom with fairness
and respect for the constitution
the laws of our nation and its people
he has a keen legal mind and a love of
the law that are obvious to anyone who's
heard him ask questions or read his
decisions and certainly to someone who
clerked for him on the supreme court and
who has had the benefit of his
mentorship over many many years
you've had broad experience in your
stellar legal career that'll make you a
unique contributor to the supreme court
you've worked as a lawyer or as a judge
in just about every level of our legal
system engage in just about every area
of federal law
your experiences as a private practice
attorney with large law firms as a
federal public defender
as vice chair of the u.s sentencing
commission and your near decade of
service as a federal judge have given
you insights into the ways that our
constitution our statutes our sentencing
guidelines and judicial decisions all
come together
to directly impact individuals families
and our communities
you're able to perceive the full sweep
of our law without losing sight of the
human beings the individuals and
families impacted by it caught up in it
and it is critically important in my
view that we have justices on the
supreme court with this practical and
proximate view
you began your legal career with the
invaluable experience of clerking for
judges at the federal district court at
the circuit court and for justice breyer
on the supreme court judges appointed by
presidents of both parties you developed
your career as a legal advocate in
private practice and in the federal
public defender service
as part of this work you took on complex
cases
involving challenging and unsettled
areas of the law you worked pro bono on
behalf of clients without regard to
their political views or the political
consequences of those cases
and you helped ensure bedrock
constitutional guarantees in our legal
system held strong even in times of
great stress and crisis
the work you did in these roles
distinguished you as a talented
appellate litigator with a formidable
legal mind
you helped to craft policy as counsel to
the u.s sentencing commission the
independent agency within the judicial
branch that establishes sentencing
guidelines followed by all federal
judges and then years later you served
again on the commission as its vice
chair
while on the u.s sentencing commission
you partnered with colleagues whose
perspectives on the law span the
ideological spectrum and together you
enacted meaningful reforms designed to
reduce unjust disparities and increase
fairness in sentencing
the days ahead i expect to discuss your
sentencing commission experience with
you in some detail
nearly all the decisions you were part
of while serving on the commission were
unanimous and they grew out of a careful
consideration of highly complex numerous
factors and involved commissioners
working hard to achieve common ground
in at least one notable instance you
ended up joining two conservative
commissioners to oppose an amendment
because you thought the law required a
different result and you followed the
law
something that often gets lost in our
debates and discussions about the
supreme court is that many in some terms
the majority of supreme court decisions
are unanimous
or decided by very broad majorities
these decisions are every bit as
critical to the rule of law and the
functioning and legitimacy of the court
as the handful that are very contentious
and widely discussed publicly your
service on the sentencing commission and
your time on the circuit court have
prepared you to be a positive force for
consensus
among the justices in this challenging
chapter in american history
i also think we will have some extended
discussions this week about your record
of service on the federal bench you were
confirmed to the federal district court
for the district of columbia in 2013 and
have written more than 500 published
opinions you were confirmed to the d.c
circuit court of appeals last year
and in your near decade as a judge
you've authored opinions in cases
spanning a myriad of complicated issues
from administrative law to civil rights
from criminal environmental matters
labor and employment law national
security and sovereign immunity
immigration law and many more
your rich complex and deep decisional
record gives us the best possible
evidence of what kind of justice you
will be
and i've concluded you are judicious
and impartial
great qualities for injustice
in every case you methodically consider
the party's arguments the relevant facts
and the law including of course the
foundation of the constitution the text
of applicable statutes
and the precedents that apply and
ultimately from what i've seen you come
to a decision based on that methodology
not on any particular policy preferences
or activism
this committee has also received a
striking outpouring of support for your
nomination from a very broad range of
sources
i'm certain we'll be hearing about some
of the more enthusiastic statements in
detail in the coming days but in several
of the letters i've had a chance to
review personally i've been struck these
were letters from lawyers that held
appointed positions in republican
administration
administrations letters from a prominent
law enforcement organizations federal
judges appointed by republican
presidents they praise your
qualifications your character your
experience and your commitment to
even-handed and impartial judging and
the rule of law
this is the fourth supreme court
nomination process in which i'm
participating as a senator and i know
our role in confirming a justice to the
highest court is among the most solemn
obligations we have as senators
as we begin this week's hearings i
remain hopeful
that we can come together as a committee
and engage in respectful good faith
bipartisan consideration of your
nomination
i look forward to your testimony this
week i'm excited so many of my
colleagues have had a chance to get to
know you a bit to meet with you to talk
with you one-on-one and get a sense of
your your character experiences and your
background and then we'll have the
opportunity to question you to bring
that out in more detail
i have every expectation that at the end
of this week's hearings it'll be clear
to all that you are impeccably qualified
in the law
i think it'll be plain to any american
watching
you have a demonstrated record of
excellence as a jurist you will decide
cases as a justice on the basis of the
facts and the law and that you will be
faithful to the constitution
it's also my hope folks will get a
chance to meet the family that shaped
you
it was
delightful to have a few moments to get
to talk with your parents and your
brother before we began today
and to reflect on how having parents
graduates of hbcus public school
teachers who then went on to great
careers of accomplishment
johnny brown
esquire
and dr ellery brown set a great standard
but frankly to me one of the most
memorable sentences before this was in
talking to your brother katash who said
oh i'm not surprised to be here at all
this was the sort of thing for which my
sister was destined from the very start
destined perhaps
but today you are
beginning a process of walking through
this store because of courage
humility determination and a commitment
to excellence
just as another person in american
history
ruby bridges
walked through a critical door in our
history with her chin held high her back
held straight
and a fierce determination to make a
difference so you too today begin the
process of walking through this next
open door
with the sort of
sparkling wit
brilliant mind and commitment to
excellence that will make its mark in
american history
i look forward to your opening and to
this week thank you your honor
thank you senator kuhn senator sas of
nebraska
thank you chairman and uh chris was
tough to follow that was a a good
flourish at the end um judge
congratulations on your nomination uh
thanks for spending time in my office
with me uh congratulations to your
daughters and your family more broadly
this is a big day for for lots of folks
in your in your family
today the senate takes up our
constitutional duty to advise the
president on his nominee to the supreme
court the senate's advice and consent
clause and our role
is especially important these days when
we all republicans and democrats agree
that the nine justices of the court
exercise a lot of power over policy
decisions surely much much more power
than our constitution's framers ever
anticipated
so let's talk about how we got into this
mess we're here in part because of
decades and decades of recklessness by
all three branches not just one but by
all three
congress the article one branch
fails to carry out our tasks responsibly
and regularly rather than make tough
policy choices we pass incredibly vague
laws and then just push the details on
down pennsylvania avenue to unelected
bureaucrats in the article 2 branch then
the head of the executive branch
meanwhile whichever party he or she
comes from grabs more and more power
with their pens and their phones
and finally the supreme court at the top
of article 3 tends to overstep the
bounds that the constitution sets on
judicial power the court has ignored
restrictions on its authority inserting
itself into policy debates that are
supposed to be entrusted exclusively to
the two political branches and what do
we mean by that what do we mean when we
say articles one and two are political
it means that the people are in power
over articles one and two but not in the
long term over article three the men and
women in article one and article two are
supposed to be answering directly to the
american people and importantly the
american people get to hire us or get to
fire us every two four or six years
but rather than honor the roles given to
each branch activist judges usurp the
powers given to articles one and two
which articles one and two were
complicit in this overreach
many years of corroding our
constitutional order have contributed to
the polarization and the viciousness
that are poisoning our politics more
broadly we all know that our civic
health and our civic life is not healthy
and as was mentioned at the beginning of
the hearing it's at least good that this
one
got kicked off without a bunch of yokels
having to be arrested and carried from
the room when chairman grassley tried to
speak a couple years ago one of these it
took like an hour to get started that
kind of nonsense the theatrics that
happen at these hearings are because of
a broader problem
as textualists and originalists have
sought to return the court to its
historic role the supreme court
nomination process has been increasingly
punctuated with not just those theatrics
but also with lots of personal attacks
that's not what this process is supposed
to be this process is supposed to be a
careful thorough investigation of a
nominee's record to help the senate make
an informed decision on a nominee's
fitness for a lifetime appointment
that's why these hearings are supposed
to be different not because people act
like jack wagons but because the people
before us nominated by the president are
potentially going to serve for a
lifetime
that office
supreme court justice is incredibly
important yet it's also carefully
circumscribed precisely because it's a
lifetime responsibility but we know that
it's been a long time since this process
has worked like that instead this is
often a staging ground for nasty
evidence-free personal attacks
we started down this road of character
assassination in the 1980s with judge
bork's hearings and senators have been
engaged in disgusting theatrics ever
since the most recent supreme court
nominee was subjected to repeated
accusations that were nothing more than
unfiltered religious bigotry against her
the nominee before her was accused of
serial rape
aided by members of this committee
if this process were conducted in good
faith miguel and estrada and janice
rogers brown might well be on the
supreme court today but their opponents
lied and bullied rather than accepted
principled minority judges we've gotten
so used to this kind of bullying that
two years ago
the current senate majority leader stood
on the steps of the united states
capitol and screamed threats against two
sitting justices of the supreme court
that they would quote reap the whirlwind
if they ruled in a way that didn't align
with chuck schumer's political
preferences that's weird
we should all be able to pause and say
that's weird that kind of behavior
shouldn't happen
this process is broken but it's a
product of a broader brokenness in the
erosion of our constitutional structure
a lot of people are willing to take a
sledgehammer to the structure if it
offers them a quick political win and
it's no coincidence that as more of us
embrace and ends justifies the means
philosophy of our jobs
which are supposed to be jobs of public
trust our politics becomes uglier more
brutal and more pathological
well we have an opportunity today to do
something different and we can
demonstrate that the congress can carry
out its constitutional duty responsibly
without a lot of that past ugliness
judge jackson has served for the last
nine months on the prestigious u.s
circuit court of appeals for the d.c
circuit
and before that you spent eight years on
the d.c district court she has a long
record of public service and a long
roster of colleagues and friends who
will testify to her professionalism the
president believes that she should have
a lifetime seat on the supreme court and
it's the job of this body to evaluate
that recommendation on its merits so
what should we be looking for we should
start with judicial philosophy the
senate should have a good sense of the
principles that will guide a nominee's
decision-making on the bench
a robust and thorough judicial
philosophy can help help us understand
how when faced with difficult or
unprecedented decisions as the court
occasionally is and i would just like to
compliment senator coons a minute ago
mentioning that a huge huge share of
decisions that come out of the supreme
court are actually nine to zero they
just tend to not be the ones that make
the headlines but they're incredibly
important um and the public trust that
we need to restore in all three branches
of government would be well served by us
paying more attention to some of those
uh nine zero decisions but the ones that
tend to be most contentious
and the ones that tend to generate the
most headlines are the occasions where
judges have to figure out what they do
in areas which are gray and ambiguous
where the law might not be clear and so
it make it's incredibly important for a
judge to tell us how she or he works out
those principles in times that are are
new and confusing this will make their
rulings more durable and sound and it
will help rebuild public trust
in the court and in the government more
generally unfortunately too many of the
court's decisions do not rest on solid
constitutional foundations and reliable
legal reasoning justices have too often
written decisions to claim partisan
policy victories and then retrofit bad
legal reasoning or political decision
making to justify that ruling
some of the most divisive cases in the
court's recent history fit that bill
it's for that reason that while we
should all respect the ginsburg rule the
idea that judges sitting before this
panel should not weigh in on
hypothetical cases that are likely to
come before the court nominees do
nonetheless have a duty to be very clear
about their judicial philosophy their
legal views and their interpretive
principles the american people should
not be asked to consent to any nominee
who operates on principles that are
obscure confused or concealed that means
that each of us has a job to do in these
hearings it is our job on the senate
judiciary committee to ask questions
that help give the american people a
clear view of the nominee
it's judge jackson's job to make her
philosophy clear and well understood and
at the end of a constructive hearing a
nominee will have given us a good sense
of how she thinks about the
constitutional structure what it does
and doesn't do and the key pillars that
support it most fundamentally the
separation of powers and our carefully
calibrated system of checks and balances
throughout this process we should all
remember that a supreme court justice is
not a lawmaker by another name a supreme
court justice performs a crucial but
limited function in our political system
namely to interpret and fairly apply the
text to the law as written and as
understood at the time it was adopted
a forthcoming nominee will make clear a
commitment to uphold that purpose which
is the court's true purpose not the
purpose concocted for it by decades of
political use abuse and overreach a good
nominee will show a commitment to the
strict protection of enumerated rights
not the fabrication of unenumerated
rights through contorted readings an
excellent nominee will offer a robust
judicial philosophy that makes sound
decisions more likely and more trusted
by the public
chairman i look forward to hearing from
judge jackson this coming week thanks
senator sass senator blumenthal of
connecticut thanks mr chairman
good afternoon
judge
thank you for being here thank you to
your family and thank you to
president biden
for his vision and wisdom and courage
in nominating you
uh first on a personal note for all of
your extraordinary
accomplishments and your immense
distinction you have shown two qualities
that
are rare among powerful accomplished
people kindness and humor
and you're obviously a good listener
because you're doing a lot of listening
here today
as you've seen
we're likely to
hear more than a few straw men today
worn talking points imagined grievances
but this hearing really should be about
you
not about us
historic is a word often overused in
this place where a lot of history
is made but today seems truly to merit
it
certainly it is an inflection point
an inflection pinnacle
for our nation the appointment of a
black woman to the united states supreme
court let's be very blunt
should have happened years ago
this day is a giant leap into the
present for our country and for the
court
the appointment of a black woman
to the court
means that
your
service
will make the court look more like
america
hopefully too it will make the court
think
more like
america
we will never know in detail all of the
challenges and obstacles that you've
overcome
to be here
today
but we know for sure that you will bring
an important perspective in fact a
unique perspective
to a court
that deeply needs it
representation matters for the
legitimacy and credibility
of our judicial system judges are the
face and voice
of justice people walking into
your courtroom or any other in this
country look to the human being
not just to the robes
too often our courts are isolated
seemingly sterile marble halls lacking
emotional intelligence
or sensitivity to the impact they have
on people
a fact that you
clearly and dramatically
understand
what really knocked me over in our
meeting was the fact that
you discussed your job as a judge
in terms of the people who are affected
by
your rulings the people whose lives are
touched
by the justice system whether it's
victims as criminal defendants
or as people dealing with a personal or
professional conflict
you will be the first public defender on
the court
you understand our justice system
uniquely through the eyes of people who
couldn't afford
a lawyer
they couldn't afford their own lawyer
and you
advocated for them
you will also bring the court
extraordinary intellect
and character as well as diverse
personal and indeed
professional experience your presence
will ensure the court more fully and
deeply understands the lives and
experiences
of everyday
americans you grew up as the daughter of
two public servants
public school teachers and
administrators you're the niece of
uncles who have impressive law
enforcement
careers including one as miami's chief
of police and you also have family
members who have struggled as do
every american
and you've advocated for defendants
standing accused of serious crimes
as well as sentencing defendants who
have been convicted of such crimes you
are an immensely devoted parent
who has achieved eye-popping
professional distinction
you've had a long career already as a
distinguished jurist
in fact you would bring more experience
as a trial judge than any current
justice on the supreme court
now i'd like to address directly
the importance of your work as a public
defender i was a prosecutor and a law
enforcement for a while four years as
u.s attorney in
20 years as connecticut's attorney
general
and as a prosecutor i know
the system works best when there are
good lawyers on both sides my worst
nightmare as a prosecutor
was a defendant representing himself
my second worst nightmare
was
an incompetent counsel representing a
defendant
because i know effective representation
on the other side means
more likely an error-free
trial
i'd also like to
address
an issue that's been raised first by
senator durbin and then by
senator graham i'm likely to be followed
by
one or more colleagues who have raised
allegations
about your record that are simply
unfounded in fact and
indeed irresponsible they're unproven
and unprovable
they're simply false
one of the first lessons
that you learn as a prosecutor
is
never to promise a jury evidence
that you don't have
there is simply no evidence to support
these unfounded attacks in fact a
commentary in the national
review
cited by senator durbin said
about those
allegations they are meritless
to the point of demagoguery
importantly your record as a jurist also
reveals impartiality you're a proven
unifier
and a consensus builder someone who can
build bridges among colleagues
even adversaries
not surprisingly you've been confirmed
on a bipartisan basis three times by the
senate
you've received glowing endorsements
from former judges
who are stalwarts of the conservative
movement the court needs a bridge
builder
now more than ever it has become more
polarized more politicized more divided
than at any point in our history
and it faces a crisis of legitimacy
as a result
dark money special interest groups have
sought to radically reshape the court
their recent selection of justices was
to a remarkable degree
outsourced to ideological groups with
the express aim of remaking the court
in the image of the far-right
conservative
movement
this court has signaled
that it will continue to overthrow
well-established precedents
after disingenuously promising us
members of this
committee that it would respect those
precedents
and instead it
threatens to adopt preferred policy
views
i revere
the united states supreme court i
clerked for a justice myself harry
blackman i've argued four times before
the court i'm deeply concerned
that
this court
is careening toward a precipice that
will gravely threaten
its role in our history that it is out
of step with america
and that it is losing the trust and
respect of the american people that are
essential
to its authority
trust in the united states supreme court
is at a new law
a new low
the supreme court has no armies no
police force to enforce its decisions
its authority depends on its credibility
and the respect and trust of the
american people
my hope is that you will help
to restore that trust that you will
re-inspire
the confidence of the american people
in the court
i traveled as did my colleague senator
klobuchar to poland just a week ago
and i saw people
fleeing bombs and destruction
people
mostly women and children who wanted
nothing more than the kinds of freedoms
that we have in this country
we have an obligation to preserve them
and my hope is that your nomination will
help us do so thank you i look forward
to your
testimony
thank you senator blumenthal senator
grassley just asked me what the plan is
the plan is to recognize two more
senators and then then take a 30-minute
break for lunch is that okay sir
judge
all right we have
senator hawley of missouri
thank you very much mr chairman judge
congratulations on your nomination it's
nice to see you again congratulations to
all of your family i know this is a big
moment for you and for them and rightly
so i enjoyed our meeting a couple of
weeks ago you know as i've said to folks
who've asked about it one of the things
i particularly appreciated about our
meeting besides how much time you gave
me was how candid and forthcoming you
were which i really respected and i look
forward to a candid conversation again
in the days that come and by the way i'm
admiring how you're sitting so uh
stoically through all of this uh all the
senator talk but uh i'm looking forward
to visiting with you again you did me
the the honor when we sat down of being
very candid and i hope i was candid with
you i've been candid since i want to be
candid with you today so you know
exactly what it is i want to talk about
and so you know exactly where my head is
at so let me let me say
a few things that i'm concerned about
aspects of your record that trouble me
this will come as no surprise i've said
it in public already but i want to be
again very candid in the interest of an
open and honest discussion and specifics
so here are i hope in the next couple of
days some of the cases
from your time on the on the court the
district court the federal district
court that i hope that we can talk about
let me just run through a few of them so
you know exactly which ones i mean
united states versus hawkins this was a
child pornography case where the
defendant distributed multiple images of
child porn possessed dozens more
including videos
the federal sentencing guidelines
recommended a sentence of 97 to 121
months in prison
prosecutors recommended 24 months in
prison
judge jackson gave the defendant three
months in prison
united states versus chasen there's
that case the defendant possessed
48 files of child pornography the
federal guidelines recommended 78 to 97
months in prison the prosecutor
recommended the same
judge jackson sentenced him to 28 months
united states versus cooper
there the defendant possessed dozens of
images of child pornography
and distributed i should say distributed
dozens of images of child pornography
possessed over 600.
federal guidelines recommended 151 to
188 months in prison that's a long time
the prosecutor recommended 72 months
judge jackson gave the defendant 60
months
which was the lowest sentence permitted
by the law
the united states versus down that's a
case where the defendant distributed 33
graphic images and videos of child
sexual assault to an anonymous messaging
app unfortunately practice that's
becoming more common the federal
guidelines recommended
70 to 87 months in prison
the prosecutor recommended 70 months in
prison judge jackson sentenced him to
only 60 months again that's the lowest
level that was permitted by law in that
case
the united states versus stewart
the defendant there distributed scores
of images of children suffering sexual
abuse
the guidelines recommended 97 to 121
months in prison the prosecutor
recommended 97 months in prison
judge jackson gave him 57 months
in the united states versus sears the
defendant distributed over 100 videos of
child pornography
the guidelines recommended 97 to 121
months in prison
the prosecutor recommended 97 months in
prison
judge jackson gave him 71 months
in the united states versus savage the
defendant was convicted of traveling
across state lines to engage in sexual
intercourse with a child and also
possess six
separate thumb drives of child
pornography the guidelines recommended
46 to 57 months in prison the prosecutor
recommended 49 months in prison judge
jackson sentenced him to 37
months in prison now those are seven
cases
that represent as near as we can tell
all of judge jackson's cases dealing
with child pornography from her time on
the district court in which she had some
discretion to hand down a sentence
there's some other cases in which the
law she didn't have any discretion the
law bound the sentence that she had to
had to give and what concerns me and
i've been very candid about this is that
in every case in each of these seven
judge jackson handed down a lenient
sentence that was below what the federal
guidelines recommended and below what
prosecutors requested and so i think
there's a lot to talk about there and i
look forward to talking about it now i
will note
that some have said that the federal
sentencing guidelines are too harsh
on child sex crimes especially child
pornography i've heard that argument a
lot in recent days the chairman quoted
someone earlier today who takes that
point of view i'll just be honest i
can't say that i agree with that
i mean the amount of child pornography
in circulation has absolutely exploded
in recent years here's a new york times
report from 2019 i'm quoting now
last year tech companies reported over
45 million online photos and videos
of children being sexually abused more
than double what they found the previous
year
the report goes on to say this
20 years ago these online images were a
problem
10 years ago they were an epidemic
now the crisis is at a breaking point
unfortunately it's even worse than that
just last week the national center for
missing and exploited children
reported finding 85
million files of child pornography in in
2021 of course this committee has heard
testimony from prosecutors and others
who are grappling with the problem of of
how to get at this porn and those who
distribute it how to prosecute them and
hold them accountable here's my point i
i think it's difficult against this
backdrop to argue
that the sentencing guidelines are too
harsh or outmoded or that we should be
somehow treating child porn offenders
more leniently
than the guidelines recommend but i want
to be clear about this but those
arguments that i've just been rehearsing
those who say that
those are that's not what judge jackson
has said
she hasn't had the chance yet to respond
to this and she deserves that chance so
others have made these arguments i don't
agree with them
but i think it's important we hear from
judge jackson and we'll have the chance
to in coming days
and i i think again the the candid that
judge jackson has shown previously i
look forward to and she deserves the
ability to speak for herself on this
issue
so i will just say in closing mr
chairman some have asked why did i raise
these questions ahead of the hearing why
not wait until the hearing and uh spring
them on judge jackson as it were and my
answer to that is very simple i'm not
interested in trapping judge jackson i'm
not interested in trying to play gotcha
i'm interested in her answers because i
found in our time together that she was
enormously thoughtful enormously
accomplished
and i suspect has a coherent view and
explanation and a set of thinking way of
thinking about this that i look forward
to hearing and i think she deserves the
chance to talk about it i think the
american people deserve the chance to
hear her answers
so they're my concerns judge they're the
cases i imagine there'll be others that
we can talk about on other subjects but
i'd like to talk about those so you know
exactly where i'm coming from thanks
again for giving me the time a few weeks
ago congratulations again i look forward
to finally hearing from you tomorrow
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
hawley uh certainly the judge deserves
to be heard on that type of a charge
senator carono
thank you mr
chairman judge jackson aloha to you and
your family
and all of your friends i also note that
there are members of the u.s house here
to support you as well as members of the
public so aloha too all of you
congratulations
jackson on all that you have
accomplished throughout your
life and career
i realized that a lot of your background
and experiences have already been cited
but there are things that are worth
repeating so i'm going to repeat some of
them
you're the national champion in speech
and debate as a high schooler
you have undergraduate and law degrees
from harvard each with honors three
clerkships in federal court including
one at the supreme court for justice
breyer whom you have been nominated to
replace
you have an accomplished career as a
lawyer
at the trial and appel levels both in
private practice and as a public
defender
two stints at the u.s sentencing
commission including as vice chair
nine years as a federal judge first in
the d.c district court and currently in
the d.c circuit court
and now you've been nominated to the
united states supreme court
i have enjoyed reviewing your record and
getting to know you over the past few
weeks and now the american people will
get to know you over the course of this
week
beyond your impressive credentials here
are a few other things i want the
american people to know
you're born in washington dc to two
public school teachers
you moved to miami florida at a young
age so your dad could go to law school
and you were inspired to pursue a career
in law by watching your dad study for
his law classes at the kitchen table
you first considered attending harvard a
thought that hadn't previously entered
your mind after attending a speech and
debate competition on the harvard campus
during high school
and then you thought this is possible
you've been confirmed three times by the
senate all on a bipartisan basis first
to the sentencing commission and later
to be judged on the d.c district court
and the d.c circuit court
you're the second generation in your
family to get to go to college and work
extremely hard to get to where you are
today
you're a wife and mother of two children
clearly your life and your career have
more than prepared you to serve on our
nation's highest court
which is why it is no surprise that
there is broad consensus across the
political spectrum that you are an
imminently qualified and fair
person to serve on the secretary on the
supreme court
as former fourth circuit judge
michael luddick a george h.w bush
appointee said you are quote
as highly credentialed and experienced
in the law as any nominee in history
end quote
in history that's over 200 years
23 attorneys general said judge jackson
is a highly qualified legal mind who has
been at the forefront of the legal field
for decades and will serve our nation
well as the first black woman to serve
on the u.s supreme court
a group of law enforcement officers from
across the country said quote judge
jackson bridges a depth of character
brings a depth of character public
service and judicial service that leads
to but one conclusion she is eminently
qualified to serve on the supreme court
of the united states end quote
you are an accomplished jurors having
issued nearly 600 opinions
that demonstrate a clear
even-handed approach to the law you have
sided with workers
with employers
for and against the government four
prosecutors and four criminal defendants
former d.c circuit judge thomas griffith
a george w
bush appointee summed it up best when he
said you judge jackson quote
you will adjudicate based on the facts
and the law and not
as a partisan end quote
having reviewed your record i strongly
agree with the statement
but you are not just extremely qualified
to serve as a supreme court your
nomination is of course an historic one
the supreme court has existed for over
233 years
and over 115 justices in the history of
the supreme court
only five of them have been women
only two have been black and not a
single one has been a black woman
this is a court that has decided cases
that have had
sweeping effects on everyday life
as mine a number of my colleagues have
pointed out including decisions that
have solidified rights for the lgbtq
plus
community
decisions that have impart women
that have strengthened unions and more
but this is also the same court that has
throughout the course of history upheld
slavery
jim crow laws and the unlawful
internment of japanese americans
for over 233 years the individual making
decisions that have altered the course
of this country
have almost exclusively been white men
it's pretty remarkable when you consider
the power that this court has and the
historical lack of diversity of the
people who exercise that power the
justices
but instead of celebrating the long
overdue diversity just
judge jackson would bring to the court
some of my republican colleagues and
public figures have attempted to
undermine your qualifications through
their pejorative use of the term
affordable
affirmative action and they have implied
you were solely nominated due to your
race and not for other factors
apparently some have even claimed that
you need to show your lsat scores
to determine whether you are a top legal
mind this is incredibly offensive and
condescending
let me be clear your nomination is about
not about fulfilling a quota
it is about time it's about time that we
have a highly qualified highly
accomplished black woman on the supreme
court it's about time our highest court
better reflects the country it serves
it's about time that black women and
girls across the country can finally see
themselves who look like them sitting
on the highest court making decisions
that will impact
their lives
and they will know that it is possible
for them to do the same
one cannot overstate the importance of
representation
your experiences and your background as
a trial judge public defender a mother a
black woman and so much more provide you
with a uniquely different perspective
than any of the eight other justices on
the court
like your mentor justice breyer i know
you will encoura you will engage
with the other justices both liberal and
conservative
you are a consensus builder
to share their perspectives
challenge their views and shape the
court's
direction
for the better
with the personal and professional
diversity you bring you will expand the
experience and knowledge
of the supreme court and the decisions
the court makes will be better as a
result
before i end i also wanted to mention i
was so glad to hear you reference
constance baker motley during your
introductory press conference at the
white house
constance baker motley
was an icon of the civil rights movement
as a lawyer for the naacp legal defense
fund she helped craft the argument in
brown v board of education
that finally
put an end to separate but equal
she was the first black woman to argue
before the supreme court
ultimately arguing ten cases before the
court and winning nine including the
case that allowed james meredith to
enroll
at the university of mississippi
she became the first black woman
appointed as a federal judge serving on
the southern district of new york for 20
years and in a world free from
discrimination she may have been the
first black woman to sit on the supreme
court some 50 years ago
as you said at your press conference you
stand on judge motley's shoulders
i have no doubt there will be a
generation of young girls who will stand
on yours
i also have no doubt that you will
respond forcefully
to some of the allegations that have
been lodged against you
judge jackson
i congratulate you
and your family on this historic
nomination
i look forward to hearing from you this
week mahalo and aloha
thank you senator hirono now we're going
to break and return at 205 when you will
hear this and we're back in business in
the meantime
thank my colleagues and i particularly
thank the judge for her patience
[Music]
is
okay
right
where's
this way
great
we're screaming
come on
quick one
good easier
uh
[Music]
um
uh
is
is
[Music]
after seven years
had everything from
vegetable peelers and coffee like i
moved into murphy's
and then as maggie and i tried
today on saturday
there's just a little bit of brush and
then three lanes of traffic and a
concrete barrier
but i
um
which
um
okay
oh
[Music]
um
okay
uh
all right
is
is
okay
[Music]
my life
is
oh my god
um
yes
is
yeah so
um
good one
wow
what
what
when she
goes
like this
you
what is
yes
[Music]
[Music]
one two three
four
five
six seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
twelve
thirteen it works it works now okay
you know before you start
it was just truly
uh
right
okay
yes
uh
okay
hey
fire
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
yes
uh
sushi
vegan
okay
you're not meat
thank you
thank you
the senate judiciary committee will
resume and next up is the senator from
arkansas senator cotton for opening
statement
i welcome judge jackson
and her family and i congratulate her on
her nomination
this is an important occasion the biden
administration is waging a war on the
rule of law the separation of powers and
the constitution
the lawlessness of the administration
highlights the importance of judges who
faithfully apply the law
to understand the ongoing power grab
let's consider president biden's failed
nominee to lead the departments of
justice
uh
atf the manny nominated can only be
described as a anti-gun zealot thanks to
the courage of some of my democratic
colleagues
that
nominee was withdrawn
but it's disturbing that the president
was ever willing to nominate someone who
planned to shred the second amendment
and ban virtually every modern
hunting rifle
in america
just a few weeks ago the biden
administration tried to twist the
authority of the occupational safety and
health administration a relatively
obscure agency designed to regulate
things like ladder safety on
construction sites
and use it as a weapon to force
virtually every american to choose
between getting vaccinated or losing
their livelihood
thankfully the supreme court struck down
that unlawful power grab
or look at the southern border where joe
biden and his secretary of homeland
security steadfastly refuse to enforce
our laws
as a result
two million illegal aliens streamed
across our borders just last year
and less than six months ago the
attorney general of the united states
himself a former judge
ordered that federal prosecutors the fbi
and even the national security division
of the department of justice be
mobilized against parents who dared
question the entrenched teachers unions
who are poisoning their children with
racist vitriol known as critical race
theory
as justice galileo was fond of saying
every banana republic has a bill of
rights
but it's nothing more than a parchment
barrier without free and fair elections
without separated powers without the
rule of law and without an independent
judiciary
to uphold it all
perhaps recognizing what justice scalia
meant the progressive left is not just
threatening the rights of americans but
are very system of constitutional
government
those on the left including some of my
colleagues here in the senate including
on this committee
want to pack the supreme court
i would hope that anyone nominated to
the court would have no problem echoing
the words of justice ginsburg and
justice breyer
both of these liberal lions have said
that expanding the supreme court to
achieve favored legal and political
outcomes is a dangerous idea and that
the court should have nine justices and
no more
but for some political outcomes on the
court
are exactly their goal
the democratic leader senator schumer
stood on the steps of the supreme court
almost exactly two years ago and yelled
at specific justices quote
you have unleashed the whirlwind and you
will pay the price and added quote
you won't know what hits you if you go
forward with these awful decisions end
quote
the chief justice rightly condemned
these words
again i hope any nominee to the court
would be comfortable condemning these
words from senator schumer as well
the supreme court is not the only
constitutional limit on power that the
left would like to destroy
the associate attorney general of the
united states has said that she believes
that every single american every single
american
and every single institution in this
country
are inherently racist and the very
concepts of the rule of law and equal
justice for all are actually quote code
words that's what she said code words
for some kind of twisted secret racism
these threats the rule of law are not
merely theoretical
we are witnessing a breakdown
of society
there are many americans who no longer
feel safe today parents are scared
to walk down the streets that used to be
free from crime
in 2020 anarchists rioters and left-wing
street militias
raged across the country and murders
increased at the fastest rate in history
in the first year of the biden
administration violent crime got even
worse
it's no coincidence that this violence
violence came as localities and states
pushed to defund the police and reduce
the punishment for criminals
career criminals are committing violent
crimes and going free
under the guise of a supposedly more
equitable justice system
and liberal judges who have more
sympathy for the victimizers than for
the victims are a big part of the
problem
the bite administration is committed to
these soft on crime policies like ending
cash bail to create a catch and release
system for violent criminals
progressive soros prosecutors who are
supported by the biden administration
have nullified entire sections of law to
destroy our criminal justice system from
within
consequences are obvious skyrocketing
violent crime embolden gangs and drug
overdoses reaching numbers never before
seen
in american history
if judge jackson is confirmed her
decisions will have a direct impact on
the safety of the american people
so we're going to look at her past
decisions and her statements
because the best predictor of future
performance is past performance
that brings us to today
we're asked to determine whether the
president's nominee to the supreme court
is able and willing to meet these vital
challenges
i enjoyed meeting with
judge jackson last week in my office
we had a good conversation and over the
next few days i'll have many more
questions
let's be clear about this the
confirmation hearing is not a test of
how well nominees can filibuster
or how many questions they can avoid
answering
it's true that there is a tradition of
avoiding
any stances on how one might rule in
specific cases if confirmed and there's
good reason for that
but that's not a license to refuse to
discuss one's views of the law
how one would go about conducting legal
interpretation
or one's philosophy as a judge
judge jackson isn't nominated to be a
district judge or a circuit judge this
time around so it is not enough to say
that she will approach
things with integrity and fairness and
faithfully apply precedence set by
higher courts
just as you wouldn't hire a teacher who
refused to say anything about their
teaching philosophy other than that they
would look at the curriculum and
appropriately teach the students it's
not enough to say only that one would
look at the facts and arguments in the
case and fairly apply the law
that wouldn't tell us anything about how
one plans to do the job
how one interprets the law how one
understands our constitution
it's no secret that i voted against
judge jackson's nomination to the
circuit court last year but i want to
give her the opportunity to show why i
should vote for her this time
so i want to be clear about what would
convince me to support any supreme court
nominee
i'm looking for a justice who will
uphold the constitution
not use it to invent new so-called
rights
i'm looking for a justice who
understands the constitution means what
it says and does not mean what it
doesn't say
someone who understands it is not up to
nine
unaccountable unelected politicians in
black robes decide some new evolving
meaning of the constitution based on
public opinion polling or views of the
legal elite
i'm looking for a justice who realizes
that a so-called living constitution
really means that the constitution is
dead
instead we should have an enduring
constitution as justice scalia contended
i'm looking for a justice who
understands that there is a process for
updating the constitution and that
process is by amending the constitution
i will not support anyone who seeks to
rewrite the constitution from the bench
rather than through our constitutional
amendment process
i'm looking for a justice who
understands that nobody is above the law
and will not coddle criminals or put
illegal aliens ahead of american
citizens
looking for a justice who will protect
the right to life of innocent infants
instead of caving to the abortion lobby
creating whole new swaths of law out of
whole cloth
i'm looking for a justice who will make
decisions based on the law
not based on their personal experiences
or preferences not on empathy not on
desired political outcomes
but on the law and the constitution
if judge jackson is confirmed her job
will be simple
leave the legislating to congress
and to elected accountable office
holders in our states
and our municipalities
zealously protect the separation of
powers and don't overturn laws unless
they violate the constitution
i look forward to these hearings thank
you very much
thank you senator cotton senator booker
of new jersey thank you very much mr
chairman
judge your honor it's very good to see
you forgive me when you were in my
office you were focused on the hearings
and a lot of the substance and had such
great questions i could not stop being
just joyous that you were sitting in my
office and i couldn't stop bringing up
to you the historical nature of this
forgive me i grew up in a small black
church where i was taught to make a
joyous noise unto the lord and this is
not a normal day for america we have
never had this moment before
and i just want to talk about uh the joy
i know tomorrow in the coming hearings
we're going to have tough
hard questions but please
let me just acknowledge the fact that
this is not normal it's never happened
before the senate is poised right now to
break another barrier we are on the
precipice of shattering another
ceiling another glass serum it's a
ceiling it's a sign that we as a country
are continuing to rise
to our collective cherished highest
ideals
i i just feel this sense of overwhelming
joy as i see you sitting there as i see
your family sitting behind you
you know the greatness of america
is that these imperfect geniuses at our
founding founded a nation different than
any before on in human history
it wasn't because we all prayed the same
or looked the same they put forth in a
constitution the best hopes for humanity
and the story of america i think
mostly these 108 white men they were
extraordinary patriots who helped shape
this country
but now we are seeing to the highest
court in our land
a hopeful day like this
that that so many of the people so much
of the rich talent of our nation
who could not scarcely ever dream of
sitting on the supreme court
now we are showing that we will indeed
go deep into the waters of our nation
and pull forth the best talent
extraordinary legal talent comes from
all backgrounds i know
that in our nation for the 200 plus
years of our history there have been
extraordinarily talented black people
men and women muslim men and women from
the founding of our nation
we've seen extraordinary indigenous men
and women all who probably could have
added to the greatness of our courts but
they were denied that
opportunity
i believe we say these words justice for
all but there are many of people who
feel those words have been diminished by
the lack of representation the lack of
avenues for talented people to ascend to
our courts but fortunately thanks to the
sacrifices of all americans people on
both sides of the political aisle we
have begun to see more and more
diverse americans slowly
get on to our federal courts
my family celebrated that
i was born in 1969 the year that
president johnson nominated thurgood
marshall the first african-american to
serve on the supreme court it shook the
wonderful foundations of our nations and
he became a symbol to all of us black
and white
of what a supreme court justice can be
and then ronald reagan
1981 roughly 200 plus years since the
founding of our nation put justice
sandra day o'connor that was not a
normal moment
it was a moment to rejoice
and now we've seen president obama put
justice
so sonia sotomayor the first hispanic on
the court
and what i'm seeing in this congress my
colleagues and i
doing is we are opening the doors of
diverse talent to our federal courts in
ways we've never seen before think about
this president biden has nominated the
first ever article iii muslim judge to
our federal courts
he nominated the first openly lgbtq
woman to serve on our federal courts he
nominated native american and asian
american candidates who have appeared
before this committee incredibly
talented individuals worthy of their
positions now act in roles to the
benefit of our whole nation
they herald the truth of who we are as a
country an inclusive
multicultural nation that shows the
world the promise of a true democracy
in all over two-thirds of the confirmed
judges under the blind administration
have come from groups who historically
have not been represented on our federal
courts
so for this those reasons
and more today to me is a day of joy i
cannot
tell you how happy i am
today we should rejoice
because president biden nominated
someone that we've heard to be the 116th
associate judge of the supreme court who
is extraordinarily talented
and who also happens to be a black woman
something we've never seen before
judge jackson's nomination breaks an
artificially confining mold of our past
and opens up a more promising
potential filled future for us all as
americans it signals that this nation
will draw more deeply from all of our
talent and genius that will benefit all
americans
this is the america that most of our
families speak of from all our diverse
backgrounds an america where anybody can
achieve anything not because of the
color of their skin but because of the
content of their character and god i
can't wait for america to find out more
about your character
when the next generation behind us
looks at the highest courts in the land
this idea will be made more real in even
just the faces of the nine
you bring this wealth of experience
that's exciting to me
you've seen so many parts of our legal
system
but i just want to talk about you your
role as a public defender because that
too
is unprecedented
i have a friend uh that my uh that just
was at the
prayer breakfast here in congress brian
stevenson he has this saying he says we
have a justice system that treats you
better if you're rich and guilty than if
you're poor and innocent
i'm not sure if most americans know that
80 percent of those who go before our
nation's criminal courts
can't afford
an attorney
to this end a public defender should be
looked at as one of the most honorable
roles within our judicial system and yet
we have never had a public defender or
anyone who served as a public defender
on our highest court
and it unfortunately is very lacking
amongst all federal judges
you wrote the judge that the role the
public defender made you a better judge
you said it gave you a chance to quote
help people in need
and to promote core constitutional
values
well the sixth amendment right to the
assistance of counsel is guaranteed
regardless of wealth and despite the
nature of the accusations
i i honor that more than you know as
someone who started in legal clinics at
yale
i had my empathy expanded i had my
understanding of the struggles
of my fellow americans in ways that
shaped my entire professional career
i
love the fact that you have been a
bridge builder in so many ways
you have the support of republican
appointed judges and democratic
appointed judges heck you were confirmed
by the senate in a bipartisan manner
three times i love the fact that you
have the support of civil rights lawyers
and our largest police organizations
like the fop it is a testimony to what
this nation needs more of
people that will find ways not to
accentuate the lines that divide but try
to find
more
ties that bind us together
let me
go one note more personal
back to you sitting in my office
i i can't tell you
how before our meeting how many people
reached out to me with very emotional
moments
you know my mom's deltas
i heard from many links sisters
i i cannot tell you what it meant to me
so when you came to my office rarely i
was a little kind of
nervous even
and
and then you started talking about your
family and your parents
i want to tell your parents uh you and i
have something in common we're both
around the same age both of our parents
graduated from hbcus my dad
mr brown dr brown is also an eagle he
went to north carolina central just like
you
and
they came to dc
my mom worked in the dc public schools
miss brown just like you
and your story
the more you talked
americans from all backgrounds know what
it is to be underestimated and look down
upon
when they told you you were too
ambitious for wanting to go to harvard
you were a mom that faced career
challenges
at your private law firm how many women
can relate to that the more you spoke
about your personal story the more i
know it is an american story that folks
from all backgrounds can relate to
but there's something that really moved
me
behind you and your family is your
daughter laila
and when she was 11 years old i love
this
she wrote a letter to president obama
urging him to nominate his
her mother you to the united states
supreme court
wow and in that letter her
recommendation put forward
that you judge jackson would be quote a
great supreme court justice
i suspect after these proceedings and
please god
after your confirmation the supreme
court something new will happen in
america
that that letter from your daughter will
not be exceptional
generations of little young girls and
generations of little young boys no
matter who their parents are will have
the audacity
to write the president of the united
states
whether they're daughters of white
parents or black parents or biracial
parents or muslim and jewish parents
sikh or hindu parents we're going to see
a new generation of children talking
about their mamas
and daring to write to the president of
the united states of america that my mom
should be on the supreme court
well i want to tell your daughter right
now
that that dream of hers is so close to
being a reality some tough days ahead
but
i think it could happen
and your grandparents generation
literally this week back in 1965
when my parents were
in washington dc
and that week
there was a man named martin luther king
who began on this day of march from
selma to montgomery and when he finally
made it
on the 25th of march
he
talk to people who are losing faith in
america that we can be who we say we are
and he says
for those folks how long will we have to
wait not long because the ark of the
moral universe is long and it bends
towards justice
well today
america is witnessing
the literal bending of the ark
and the conducting of one of the most
sacred ideals of this country justice
for all i think more people at the end
of these hearings and after a senate
vote more people will believe
that we can be the nation we say we are
when we put our hand on our heart
indeed i think you
and your family are giving a lot more
people
faith
that we will achieve a nation of liberty
and justice for all thank you
thank you senator booker
senator kennedy of louisiana
hello
hello judge
um if you are
a lawyer or an american i guess it
doesn't
get any bigger or better than this um
congratulations um
in addition to honoring
the wonderful state of minnesota
and unless you correct me i am going to
assume
that your uh
your purple attire is also
meant to honor lsu
in my state
and if i squint real hard i might call
it marion blue the colors of
my southern university in louisiana
um i want
i want to compliment you and the biden
white house
for uh
selecting senator doug jones to advise
you
uh senator jones knows the senate
and the senate knows senator jones and
we
know him to be quite the intellect
but uh more important
we knowing to be a person of good
judgment and good will
and i'm
i'm glad that you've been listening to
him
um
i hope we will be able to use this
hearing today to talk about if not
implicitly at least implicitly
uh two subjects
the first is the legitimacy
of the united states supreme court
um
where does the court get its legitimacy
what can we do to enhance it
judicial
legitimacy is important
i don't need to tell you that
i'm rather fond of the constitution
i know you are too
when members of the united states
supreme court interpret it
i want the american people to believe
them i want the american people to say
well
i may not agree but the men and women
who made that decision are
intellectually honest and people of good
faith
one of the primary roles of the united
states supreme court is to uphold the
rule of law
and sometimes
justices that
have to uh uphold the rule of law when
it's not popular
sometimes justices have to uphold the
rule of law when it's not
popular with the majority of americans
boy that's tough
it's also important
sometimes not generally but sometimes
the majority can mean that just
all the fools are on the same side
and that's what the courts are for
and um
i'm rather fond of the bill of rights
too and i know you are as well
i've never believed that the bill of
rights
was there for the
for the high school quarterback
or the prom queen
they're covered by it
but the bill of rights is there to
protect the rights who
of people who don't see the world
exactly like
everybody else
or who don't look
exactly like everybody else
now unfortunately through history we
have had people
some well-intentioned
who tried to de-legitimize
the supreme court
um we had a president way back when who
tried to impeach a supreme court justice
we had another president
who wanted to pack the court
i remember the uh impeach earl warren
signs
in the warren court
um
and and most of the people who want to
delegitimize the supreme court
believe that the uh
unlike our founders and my judgment
believe that um
that that members of the supreme court
ought to be ought to be and are
politicians and robes
they believe that the united states
supreme court ought to be a mini
congress
they believe that the law
is not the law the law is supposed to
just be politics practiced in a
different way
and they believe in court packing
and they're wrong
number two i hope today that we can use
this as an opportunity
to talk about if not explicitly at least
implicitly that's what i'm going to try
to do
the appropriate balance between
representative government
and declarative government
now in representative government as you
well know
people through their elected
representatives make policy
in in declarative government
um policy is made
by the unelected the administrative
state
and the federal judiciary
now they're they're both are important
both are important i'm not saying this
is a zero sum came or either or
what's but what's just as important is
we have the appropriate balance between
representative government
and uh what i'll call deflect
declarative
government i mean we have an
administrative state did any of us ever
think it would get this big is that
healthy we need to ask ourselves that
is is it really healthy
to arrive at a circumstance where the
administrative state passes 35 laws a
year to r1
is it really healthy to have an
administrative state that makes its own
laws
interprets its own laws
and enforces its own laws
before courts
with respect to which the administrative
state appoints the judges
i think that's a fair question to ask
in terms of with respect to to to uh
declarative government and the supreme
court and and the federal judiciary
federal judges have enormous power they
have to but they do they have enormous
power
you're appointed for life
you can't be unelected
your salary can't even be reduced
and you have to have that power
judicial power is important
so is judicial restraint
i believe
that the appropriate role of the federal
judiciary
is the following
federal judges
don't make law
they don't tell us what the law ought to
be
they tell us what the law is
now i said primarily
because of course sometimes federal
judges may call
i mean you make the law of the case you
decide a case
you have to tell us what reasonable
means in terms of searches and seizures
you have to help us to find restraint of
trade after we pass a statute so of
course judges
may call
but i'm talking about uh
about the uh the proper balance i'll
leave you with the these last thoughts
um and then i'll yield back my time
um
i want you to hear the words of warner
and what
my in my opinion is is
is one of our most distinguished
supreme court justices i'm going to read
it read his words
the american people love democracy
and the american people are not fools
the people know their value judgments
are quite as good as those taught in any
law school
maybe better
value judgments after all
should be voted on
not dictated
i look forward judge
to getting to know you better
and
congratulations mom and dad
thanks senator kennedy senator padilla
thank you mr chair
judge jackson
welcome back
to the senate judiciary committee
now uh the last time you were before us
just less than a year ago
i recall that you mentioned that every
once in a while you make it a point to
walk a few blocks from your courthouse
to the national archives
as we all know
the national archives is where
the declaration of independence
the constitution
and the bill of rights
are housed
you shared that
you
go there and reflect on the
momentousness
of the office that you hold
and it's a fitting place these archives
to be reminded of our nation's highest
ideals
our pursuit of a union that is more fair
that is more free
and that is striving to be more perfect
it's also a place to see how for two and
a half centuries
our democracy has remained
a work in progress
and that it's incumbent upon all of us
yes as a nation
but each of us as individuals to
continue
making that progress
now the men who
wrote our founding documents
could never have imagined
that you would one day be here
a former public defender
a proud graduate of a public high school
a working mom
and yes the first black woman nominated
to serve on the nation's highest court
colleagues our founding fathers also
could never imagine that
the senators sitting before judge
jackson
would include the first women
to represent california
hawaii and tennessee
the first jewish man to represent
georgia
the first hispanic man to represent
texas
the first black man to represent new
jersey
nor could they have imagined that the
list would include me
i'm here as a proud son of immigrants
from mexico
who came to this country with little
formal education
but with big dreams
and a tremendous work ethic
and it's because of the decades of hard
work and sacrifice by
santos and lupe padilla
my dad is a short order cook
my mom as a housekeeper
that i've enjoyed tremendous
opportunities in my life
and that includes the honor of
representing the state of california in
the united states senate
and being the first latino to do so
so like so many of us in this room
i'm blessed to live
the american dream
now looking around you can see that the
strides that our democracy has made
toward strengthening our institutions by
including
more voices and more perspectives
judge jackson if you're confirmed we'll
take another step towards making our
government better reflect the america
that it serves
towards making the promise of america
more real
and we know that progress
doesn't come easily
breaking barriers and being the first
means not just significant opportunity
but tremendous responsibility
but judge jackson i also know you're
equipped with a tremendous record of
experience and accomplishment and you
are ready
to blaze this trail
a trail that your grandparents
may have found unfathomable
but one that your daughters
and my sons
and future generations
will now see as a natural part
of the american story
judge jackson even before
your next opinion or dissent
your appearance before us today already
begins a new chapter in our nation's
history and i can say for certain that
by the end of these hearings
those watching across the country
will know of your outstanding
qualifications your experience
and your accomplishments
which bear repeating over and over again
a public education including graduating
from miami palmetto high school
i see that smile
followed by degrees from harvard college
and harvard law school
clerkships at the federal district court
the federal court of appeals and the
united states supreme court
two years as a federal public defender
two years as a staff member of the
united states sentencing commission and
four years as its vice chair
you've been confirmed by this senate
not once
not twice
three times each on a bipartisan basis
including two
lifetime judicial appointments
and you bring nearly a decade of
judicial experience which by the way is
more than the combined total of four of
the currently sitting justices at the
time
they were nominated
so yes you are clearly
more than qualified to serve as a
justice of the supreme court of the
united states
and yes
you bring a wealth of other important
experiences and perspectives to the
court
including as a working mother and as a
black
woman now in these hearings i look
forward to speaking further about your
background your experiences both on and
off the bench
and your approach to the law
but based on our conversations already
in my review of your record
i believe
you have the expertise
the insight
and the heart
to elevate the weighty deliberations of
the supreme court
now every year the supreme court decides
dozens of cases that shape the
fundamental rights and lives of the
american people
only a small percentage of those cases
will ever be highlighted in history
books make the front page of newspapers
or go viral on social media
but the choices of the supreme court
will certainly shape the future of labor
rights voting rights
women's rights
criminal justice
immigration
technology environmental protection and
so much more
i also want to be clear about something
important
if you're confirmed
i don't expect to agree with every
detail of every decision that you make
that's not my test
that is not our test
our job on this committee is to make
sure that the next justice will honor
the rule of law
and the principle of equal justice for
all
we must ensure that the next justice
will help the supreme court live up to
its responsibility to the american
people
and yes america is watching
america is watching these hearings to
see what the future holds
not just for themselves but for the
court as well
judge jackson like you i believe in the
greatness and the promise of this nation
i believe that we can continue building
on our dream of a more perfect union
and that includes building a government
that better reflects and represents the
people that it serves
it's a dream that we've spent two and a
half
centuries struggling to realize
and while this hearing may not be the
last step on that journey it is a
momentous step forward indeed
just jackson you're an outstanding
nominee for our nation's highest court
and i thank you for your service and i
thank you for sharing your faith in
america's promise
of faith that is stronger because you
know how far our nation has come
and mr chair
before closing and with your indulgence
i'd like to share a few words in spanish
on the importance of this nomination
is
judge jackson i look forward to your
testimony over the next few days and i
thank you mr chairman
muchas gracias senator
denada
thank you mr chairman
and uh and ranking member uh
it's a real honor to now participate in
my fourth supreme court nomination and
confirmation process and judge jackson
congratulations on your nomination i
i do feel like
you and your family have every reason to
be very proud um and your daughter
apparently has pretty weighty letter
writing skills
when we met together i wanted to thank
you for the time that we spent together
i asked about your family you beamed
with pride i can understand why you have
parents brothers i'm sorry siblings
family members who are public servants
themselves and now you've gone on to do
that continue that legacy with your
in your public defender role and as a
judge you should be very proud of that
and we should also recognize the
historic nature of this
event
the first african-american female to be
put forth for confirmation for the
supreme court is quite extraordinary
i also want to recognize that
when we had
the meeting in my office i asked you why
on earth are you doing this because this
week is not going to be particularly fun
every moment of it um why why on earth
you doing this i mean you're brilliant
you're well educated you're studied in
the law
there are so many other things that you
could do
and you said that it really is the
pinnacle of your profession and that i
guess in many respects this is a
realization of a dream of yours but i
also think that it's probably putting
within reach
for many young boys and girls young men
and women the reality that they too
someday could be here before
the senate being considered for
confirmation to the highest court in the
land
so you're not only fulfilling your
dreams you're making the dreams of
others
appear to be within reach
um
i think as we go through this hearing
this week we're also going to get an
opportunity to see the content of your
character demonstrate it i for one think
you have a strong track record of
ethical values honesty integrity
respecting others and endeavoring to be
fair just and compassionate
you know confirming a supreme court
justice is one of the most important
responsibilities i think i have as a u.s
senator
the outcome of our decision will impact
millions of lives and the very structure
in the future of our constitutional
republic
supreme court justices must find answers
to some of the most pressing
constitutional and legal questions of
our time
they're confronted with complex
questions many of them don't have good
answers or at least easy ones
that's why it's critical whenever a con
we confirm a supreme court justice we
understand the nominee's judicial
philosophy
and then reconcile it with our
conception of the best mindset to bring
to the bench
in my opinion
a justice's job is to interpret the text
and words of the constitution is written
and give them their original meaning
i reject the notion that the
constitution is a living evolutionary
document that changes based on the
impulses of five
unelected justices
a good judge must understand that his or
her job isn't to legislate from the
bench and read in their preferred policy
outcomes into statutes
if the words of a statute are clear a
good judge will reach a decision based
on those words and those words alone
even if it creates an outcome they may
disagree with personally
in other words in the words of chief
chief justice roberts a good justice is
one
has one job calling balls and strikes
nothing more nothing less
sometimes that leads to rulings that
republicans like and democrats hate
other times it leads to rulings that
democrats like and republicans hate
and sometimes it leads to rulings that
everybody hates
but that's okay
that's really your job
as a supreme court justice
i had the opportunity to meet judge
jackson i said earlier and also want to
thank you for your indulgence i may have
done my interviews a little bit
differently than other ones i asked some
questions and then i had all my staff
ask a number of questions i was quite
impressed with how engaged you were
with some of the former members of the
of the judiciary committee and other
staff and i even scared one person who
was just on the job a week and a half
said you got a question for the supreme
court justice and he had a question it
was a good question and you were very
adultered in your answer
i just thought you were honest and
forthcoming i wanted you to know that
i've said that in the press i think that
you have the right temperament just
based on how i've seen you react to the
questions that are not the questions but
the statements today
and also appreciate how your unique
perspective your upbringing your family
and your experience as a former public
defender have shaped your views
as i noted during your confirmation in
the supreme court or to the circuit
court i do have some additional
questions and concerns that i want to
ask about to kind of weaved about what
weaved together or reconcile
my conception
of the uh the right
mindset for a judge going to the supreme
court
i i i'm concerned and will look into
questions over the next couple of days
and i will be here for the majority of
the hearing
to hear
to to kind of put together the
foundation that i need to make
ultimately make a decision on your
confirmation
so as i proceed with the hearing this
week
i'll be in attendance most of the time
except for breaks and i'll focus on
better understanding your writings i'm
in the middle of your thesis right now
should be finished by tomorrow morning
your political activities and opinions
with the goal of determining your
philosophy and whether or not it fits
with my conception of the right
philosophy for somebody that i would
vote to confirm
i'll listen thoroughly i'll keep an open
mind
as i do with every nominee
before this committee
but at the end of the week i'll
ultimately have to conclude whether or
not i'm comfortable with putting someone
in a lifetime position
and whether that person is likely to
have the kind of philosophy that i want
i've told
justice gorsuch justice kavanaugh and
justice barrett
that i hope and i expected that they
would take opinions that would make me
mad
and that's okay i just want to know that
they do it for the right reason
i don't want an activist at either end
of the spectrum although i think some
people some folks are okay with one end
of the spectrum not the other
if we're talking about
preserving the integrity of the court
there's no place on the supreme court
for judicial activism
and
the best thing that we can do here is
make sure that we have justices that are
going to be stewards of the constitution
respectful
of the measures that we pass out of here
and call those balls and strikes
so i look forward to the hearing
tomorrow you're going to get a lot of
questions asked i do
thank all of my colleagues in advance
for being respectful
thoughtful and
and open-minded and i look forward to
hearing your opening statement thank you
mr chairman thanks senator tillis
senator ossoff georgia
thank you mr chairman ranking member
grassley
judge jackson good
afternoon good afternoon to your family
congratulations to your family
congratulations to you for your
nomination and welcome back to the
judiciary committee
i engage in these proceedings with deep
respect for the responsibility that the
senate has
to advise and consent on the lifetime
appointment of a supreme court justice
who would be responsible for
interpreting and applying constitutional
and statutory law in the most complex
and contested
and nationally significant cases
the constitution was a groundbreaking
document when written
and still by today's standards as
amended
considering the tyranny that prevails in
much of the world
its guarantees of liberty and privacy
and due process are exceptional as a
governing document
often in our history it has fallen to
the court through its decisions
to ensure the enforcement of those
guarantees
yet our constitution's guarantees of
individual rights and equal protection
under the law remain too often and for
too many unfulfilled
for any colleagues who doubt this i
remind them of ahmad arbury's murder in
glenn county georgia just two years ago
when a young black man was shot dead in
cold blood on camera in the street
and the local authorities buried the
case
and looked the other way
only a massive civil rights mobilization
pressured state and eventually federal
prosecutors
to act
for any colleagues who doubt that those
promises remain unfulfilled to too many
i remind them that in my state you can
predict how long someone must wait to
vote by where they live and the color of
their skin
in practice the promises made in the
plain text of our constitution are still
too often broken for too many of our
fellow americans and so the court
remains essential
to that national process of becoming in
real life
what america is in text
today's hearing judge jackson is
evidence that this process continues
and above all a testament to you
personally
that in a nation still striving to
transcend the legacies of slavery and
segregation and institutionalized racism
through your brilliance and resilience
and hard work you have already rendered
great service to the nation as a federal
judge
and as a black woman you have overcome
deeply rooted obstacles
to earn nomination to our nation's
highest court
for the first time in history
alongside our constitution's exceptional
guarantees of individual rights and
equal protection is its exceptional
system of checks and balances
restraints on political power imposed by
the diffusion of
authority coequal branches
between federal and state governments
with the president and a federal
legislature directly accountable to
voters and an independent federal
judiciary
whose judges must be confirmed by
elected senators
this constitutional system has endured
and developed for nearly a quarter of a
millennium
it is resilient
but democracy remains the exception not
the norm in history and around the world
and we cannot take the survival of our
republic
for granted and so i look forward to
engaging with you
judge jackson to discuss your
perspective on the separation of powers
and the resilience of our constitution
when threatened by political actors who
would ignore the rule of law
or seek to seize power
by illegal or extraordinary means
among the court's most challenging tasks
are to grapple with unsettled law when
the stakes are highest or even
existential for individuals and for the
country and to apply the constitution
faithfully over the long arc of history
as the world changes in profound ways
and the text
of faithful constitutional
interpretation meets new facts new
contexts and new technologies
judge jackson should you be confirmed
you may serve as a supreme court justice
well into the middle of this century you
will rule on cases whose contours and
complexity we cannot yet
imagine and so among several areas of
interest i look forward to learning
how you will consider protections
against unreasonable search and seizure
in an age of ubiquitous surveillance
how you might approach disputes over war
powers
where law remains unsettled between
executive and legislative claims
how you will approach questions
pertaining to freedoms of speech
and of the press
and seek that confirmation
that you will apply the law faithfully
without regard for your own opinions as
my review of your extensive work to date
demonstrates
that i believe you will
this constitutional process of advice
and consent is vital to the integrity
and legitimacy of the court
and judge jackson on behalf of my
constituents in georgia
i look forward to engaging in this
process with you and my colleagues
mr chairman i yield thank you senator
assaf senator blackburn of tennessee
thank you mr chairman judge jackson
welcome
you are indeed to be congratulated and
your entire family with you and thank
you for your time to visit
i appreciated so much that and to your
daughters her best job is being mama
she likes that one
and uh
but we've talked today a little bit
about the momentous
occasion that this is and bringing you
forward and indeed it is because
unlike any other federal office this is
a lifetime appointment and the decisions
that you're going to make are going to
impact
rights and freedoms of every single
american citizen
and you know president biden thinks
you're the right person for the job
but it doesn't end there we do have that
role of advice and consent
and it is up to us to
carry that job out so
as you have heard repeatedly this is
going to be a fair and very thorough and
very respectful hearing and we're going
to work through
this process with some tough questions
but do it in a manner the respect that
you deserve
and we've talked some today about the
treatment of justice thomas and justice
kavanaugh
justice barrett who was questioned about
her faith
and whether that made her suitable
for the court and i know your faith is
important to you
we've also talked some about
janice rogers brown
and the treatment that she endured here
so we are going to be pleased to move
forward and focus on the issues that the
american people want to focus on because
they want to know about you
and how you're going to approach your
job and the decisions that you have made
in the past what you've written what you
have said and i've got a few areas
that i'm going to want to delve a little
bit further with you and we touched on
some of these
as we talked right now when i talk to
tennesseans one of the most important
things that they bring up is the issue
of parental rights
and wanting to be able to rear their
children as they see fit and moms and
dads are very concerned about this
progressive agenda that is being pushed
in some of our public schools
educators are allowing biological males
to steal opportunities from female
athletes in the name of progressivism
just last week an entire generation of
young girls
watched as those charged with protecting
them allowed a biological male to
compete and beat a biological woman at
the highest level of collegiate sports
some girls have been forced to share
locker rooms with biological males
rather than defending our girls those in
power are teaching them that their
voices don't matter they're being
treated like second-class citizens
and americans need a supreme court
justice who will protect our children
and will defend parents constitutional
right to decide what is best for their
own kids
and here we need a little clarity
at a time when these parental rights
appear to be under assault by the
radical left your public comments about
and i'm going to quote you the
transformative power of progressive
education
end quote these are deeply concerning
you serve on the board of a school that
teaches kindergartners five-year-old
children
that they can choose their gender and
teaches them about so-called white
privilege this school has hosted an
organization called woke kindergarten
and pushes an anti-racist education
program for white families
your public endorsement of this type
progressive indoctrination
of our children causes one great concern
when it comes to how you may rule on
cases involving parental rights parents
also know that it's only a matter of
time before we have the next pandemic
and they're concerned about more mass
mandates or lockdowns from unelected
bureaucrats that would harm their
children's mental health and stunt their
development the american people want a
supreme court justice who will protect
their families freedoms
not allow government overreach into
private family decisions
now moms that i'm speaking with raise
the issue of crime and you've
consistently called for greater freedom
for hardened criminals at the start of
the coveted 19 pandemic you advocated
and again that quote for each and every
criminal defendant in the d.c department
of corrections custody
should be released
that would have been 1500 criminals back
on the street if you had had your way
and you used the covid19 pandemic as
justification to release a fentanyl drug
dealer a bank robber addicted to heroin
and a convict who murdered a u.s marshal
into our communities but your efforts to
protect convicts began long before
the pandemic you used your time and
talent
not to serve our nation's veterans or
other vulnerable groups
but to provide free legal services to
help terrorists get out of gitmo and go
back to the fight
you also have a consistent pattern of
giving child porn offenders lighter
sentences on average you sentence child
porn defendants to over five years below
the minimum sentence recommended by the
sentencing guidelines and you have
stated publicly that it is a mistake to
assume that child pornography offenders
are pedophiles your philosophy it
appears is a backward on these issues
restrictions on children and families
and freedom for criminals
in fact your philosophy or lack thereof
may be the root of the problem here i
was concerned during our conversation
earlier this month when you told me that
you really didn't have a judicial
philosophy the american people deserve a
supreme court justice with a documented
commitment
to the
text of the constitution and
the rule of law
not a judicial activist who will attempt
to make policy from the bench without a
judicial philosophy a judge is legally
adrift and will be inclined to consider
policy rather than law you once wrote
that every judge has and i quote
personal hidden agendas end quote then
influence how they decide cases so i can
only wonder
what's your hidden agenda
is it to let violent criminals cop
killers and child predators back to the
streets
is it to restrict parental rights and
expand government's reach into our
schools and our private family decisions
is it to support the radical left's
attempt to pack the supreme court
you have praised the 1619 project which
argues the us is a fundamentally racist
country and you have made clear that you
believe judges must consider critical
race theory when deciding how to
sentence criminal defendants is it your
personal hidden agenda to incorporate
critical race theory into our legal
system
these are answers
that the american people need to know
so we are going to look at past
statements and decisions and seek
clarification
from this committee before we make our
decisions so let me close again by
congratulating you on your impressive
career and your nomination to the
nation's highest court
regardless of the outcome of the
confirmation process you and your family
should be incredibly proud of all that
you have achieved your story is a
wonderful example of the american dream
fulfilled you were able to sit here
today because you were reared and built
your career in a free country
whose laws protect equal justice and
opportunity for all to ensure that
future generations can expect the same
blessings and opportunities you receive
we need justices
who will be dedicated to justice and the
rule of law our questions to you over
the coming days are going to be tough
but they're tough by necessity because
it is our duty to discern determine
whether you will first and foremost
uphold the constitution and our nation's
founding principles thank you so much
for joining us thank you senator
blackburn all committee members have now
completed their opening statements at
this point in time we're going to have a
little shuffle of
logistics and i'll ask that the two
introducers please come forward to the
witness table
judge jackson you can take a brief rest
from the glare of the spotlight
we're fortunate today to have two
distinguished guests introducing judge
jackson
we will hear from judge thomas griffith
who served as a judge on the u.s circuit
court of appeals for the district d.c
circuit
from 2005 to 2020
and professor lisa fairfax who serves as
a presidential professor and co-director
of the institute for law and economics
at the university of pennsylvania cary
law school
judge griffith we will start with you
make sure your microphone is turned on
it's there's a red button
how's that been a while since you've
been here okay
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and members of the senate judiciary
committee i come here today as a retired
federal appeals court judge with 15
years of experience on the united states
court of appeals for the d.c circuit
i come here as a jurist appointed by
republican president george w bush
and i come here as someone who
understands that there are few greater
responsibilities under the constitution
than serving as a justice on the united
states supreme court
it takes a jurist of high character
keen intellect
deep legal knowledge and broad
experience to ensure that the judiciary
plays its unique role under the
constitution
to uphold the rule of law impartially
and not to be in the words of justice
stephen breyer partisans in robes
today i have the high honor to introduce
judge katanji brown jackson a jurist who
has all of those qualities
when president biden introduced her to
the nation a little over three weeks ago
their american people caught their first
glimpse
of judge jackson's character you may
recall that she began her remarks with
an expression of her faith in god
and her gratitude for this nation which
she rightly observed is the greatest
beacon of hope
and democracy the world has ever known
i first met judge jackson in 2013
after the senate had confirmed her
nomination to the federal district court
as a trial judge eight years later she
joined the dc circuit as an appellate
judge after another senate confirmation
i've had many opportunities to resu to
review her work and observe her work
over the years a judge and on several
occasions i reviewed her decisions on
appeal
although we did not always agree
on the outcome the law required i
respected her diligent and careful
approach her deep understanding and her
collegial manner
indispensable traits for success as a
justice on the supreme court
about her collegial manner
that important feature of the justice's
work is often overlooked although
appointed by different presidents the
justices have genuine fondness and
respect for one another we saw some of
that in their expressions of admiration
and love
for justice breyer when he announced his
retirement
the civil manner in which the justices
debate the large and vexing issues
before them is vital not only to the
success of the supreme court
but to the success of our nation
the constitution requires that
of all of us
it goes without saying that civility of
debate and respect for the differing
views of others are sorely lacking from
our public life
judge jackson's life has modeled these
qualities
perhaps most important judge jackson is
an independent jurist who adjudicates
based on the facts and the law
and not
as a partisan
time and again
she has demonstrated that impartiality
on the bench sometimes ruling in favor
of the government sometimes ruling
against the government sometimes ruling
in favor of the individual sometimes
ruling in favor of the corporation
her rule is simple
follow the law
now some think it noteworthy that a
former judge appointed by a republican
president would enthusiastically
endorse a nomination to the supreme
court by a democratic president
that reaction is a measure of the
dangerous hyper partisanship that has
seeped into every nook and cranny of our
nation's life and against which the
framers of the constitution warned us
there should be nothing unusual about my
support for a highly qualified nominee
who has demonstrated to her life's work
her commitment to the rule of law and an
impartial judiciary
my former former colleagues in the
federal judiciary michael ludwig
michael chertoff
david levy and andrew guilford each
appointed by republican presidents and
all
highly respected judicial conservatives
have also voiced their strong support
for judge jackson's
confirmation there was a time not so
long ago when bipartisan support of the
president's nomination of a highly
qualified jurist was regular order
antonin scalia was confirmed by the
senate
98 to nothing ruth bader ginsburg by a
vote of 96 to 3.
the rule of law is a fragile possibility
in the best of times
today
it is literally under attack in ukraine
and is threatened around the world
and in our own country
by autocrats and their sympathizers who
give lip service to the rule of law but
then work to undermine it at every turn
as justice scalia taught us so well for
so long
an indispensable indispensable feature
of the republic the constitution created
is an independent judiciary of judges
who have taken an oath
not to a president or a party
but to the american people
and to god
that they will be impartial
judge katanji jackson brown has
demonstrated her unwavering commitment
to that oath
i applaud this exceptional nomination
which i encourage the senate to confirm
thank you thank you judge professor lisa
fairfax
chairman durbin
ranking member grassley and members of
the senate judiciary
my name is lisa fairfax
i am a presidential professor of law at
the university of pennsylvania school of
law and co-director of its institute for
law and economics
prior to my academic career i worked at
corporate and securities law at a large
law firm
but before that i was roommate and a
very dear friend at harvard college and
harvard law school of judge katanji
brown jackson
who i am so very honored to introduce to
you today and to the american people
katanji and i met during our first days
of college nearly 35 years ago
those first moments when you wonder if
you belong
she's the friend that made sure we all
did
a woman of deep faith in god and
unyielding love for family katanji
defines friendship
she's the friend you immediately drawn
to for their outgoing and friendly
nature
as our circle of friends grew she's the
one who became the rock for us all
even though we are the same age she is
the role model who makes you believe in
what she said
you can do it and here's how
and she showed us how
by the power of her example of hard work
preparation and excellence that
transforms the seemingly impossible into
the achievable
together we poured our souls into our
studies
graduating college with honors and then
doing it all over again when we enrolled
and graduated law school with honors
we became sisters
and saw each other's families as our own
we both met our husbands when we were
students
and we were there for each other as we
walked down the aisles started our legal
careers and eventually our lives as
working mothers
my husband roger fairfax now dean of
american university's washington college
of law has described katanji's
impeccable credentials that's
distinguished her at every level of her
professional career
he also knows her as one of our
children's most favorite people in the
world
our college roommate nina simmons a top
corporate lawyer has described katanji's
unwavering work ethic
she puts her head down and gets it done
even
and perhaps especially when no one is
watching
our other college roommate antoinette
coakley a distinguished business law
professor has described katanji as a
coalition builder
we knew early on that she could be
anything she chose to be but also
that she seemed destined to be a judge
because of her ability to see all sides
and render fair and level-headed
decisions
but our tight new group of girlfriends
also knows that there's so much more to
katanji beyond her brilliant mind
there's her wonderful sense of humor
her gift of storytelling her heart of
gold that always shows up
from the first call you make for advice
about your career
to the first knock you here on the door
after learning you're diagnosed with
cancer you never have to ask she is
always there
above all katanji is humble enough not
to pretend she knows how to have it all
but she does know how to give it her all
at what she gives to her family
her friends
she also gives to the law and to this
country
a testament of her character is all the
people of different backgrounds and
beliefs who understand that essence of
katanji
we've seen that in her endorsements from
bipartisan colleagues from the bench and
the bar
and from both civil rights leaders and
members of law enforcement
and we will see it in the history she
will make
i know she is honored and humbled by the
significance of this moment
not for what it means for her
but what it means for our amazing
country
confirmation of the idea that america is
a place in which all of us can feel a
sense of belonging and all of us can
reach our fullest potential
while challenging
i would summarize nearly 35 years of
friendship in this way
by highlighting katanji's faith in god
and country
her intellectual brilliance
her goodness and grace
and a work ethic
that makes her perfectly suited for the
serious task of serving on the supreme
court
it is with tremendous pride love and
gratitude for her willingness to serve
that i introduce to you my dear friend
and an exemplar of the best of america's
promise judge katanji brown jackson
thank you thank you both professor
fairfax and judge griffith i'm sure that
the
judge jackson and her family deeply
appreciate your being here today and
your kind words i want to add to the
list of introducers man sitting behind
you senator doug jones who has
introduced judge jackson to many of us
not for the first time maybe
reintroduced it but doug thank you for
serving in this cause and for helping
the president and judge jackson thank
you all three for being with us today we
are now going to move to the next phase
of the program and that is to hear from
judge jackson
so if we can set up the table
before you sit down judge i'm going to
ask you to take the oath so
ready
please raise your right hand
affirm that the testimony you're about
to give before the committee will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god i do
let the record reflect that the judge
has answered in the affirmative
and having met that requirement you may
now proceed with your remotes
chairman durbin
ranking member grassley
and distinguished members of the
judiciary committee
thank you for convening this hearing and
for considering my nomination
as associate justice of the supreme
court of the united states
i am humbled and honored to be here
and i am also truly grateful for the
generous introductions that my former
judicial colleague
judge tom griffith and my close friend
professor lisa fairfax have so
graciously provided
i'm also very thankful for the
confidence that president biden has
placed in me
and for the kindness that he and the
first lady and the vice president and
the second gentleman have extended to me
and my family
today will be the fourth time
that i've had the honor of appearing
before this committee to be considered
for confirmation
over the past three weeks i have also
had the honor of meeting each member of
this committee separately
and i've met with 45 senators in total
your careful attention to my nomination
demonstrates your dedication to the
crucial role that the senate plays in
this constitutional process
and i thank you
and while i'm on the subject of
gratitude i must also pause to reaffirm
my thanks to god
for it is faith that sustains me at this
moment
even prior to today i can honestly say
that my life
has been blessed beyond measure
the first of my many blessings is the
fact that i was born in this great
nation
a little over 50 years ago in september
of 1970
congress had enacted two civil rights
acts in the decade before and like so
many who had experienced lawful racial
segregation first hand
my parents johnny and ellery brown
left their hometown of miami florida and
moved to washington d.c
to experience new freedom
when i was born here in washington my
parents were public school teachers
and to express both
pride in their heritage and hope for the
future
they gave me an african name
kitanji onyika
which they were told means lovely one
my parents taught me
that unlike the many barriers that they
had had to face growing up
my path was clearer so that if i worked
hard and i believed in myself in america
i could do anything or be anything i
wanted to be
like so many families in this country
they worked long hours and sacrificed to
provide their children every opportunity
to reach their god-given potential
my parents have been married for almost
54 years and they're here with me today
i cannot possibly thank them enough for
everything they've done for me
i love you mom and dad
my father in particular bears
responsibility for my interest in the
law
when i was four we moved back to miami
so that he could be a full-time law
student and we lived on the campus of
the university of miami law school
during those years my mother pulled
double duty working as the sole
breadwinner of our family while also
guiding and inspiring four-year-old me
my very earliest memories are of
watching my father study
he had his stack of law books on the
kitchen table while i sat across from
him with my stack of coloring books
my parents also instilled in me and my
younger brother kataj
the importance of public service
after graduating from howard university
kitaj started out as a police officer
following two of our uncles
after the september 11th attacks on our
country kitaj volunteered for the army
and eventually became an infantry
officer serving two tours of duty in the
middle east
kataj is here today providing his love
and support
as always
and speaking of unconditional love
i would like to introduce you to my
husband of 25 years dr patrick jackson
i have no doubt that without him by my
side from the very beginning of this
incredible professional journey
none of this would have been possible
we met in college more than three
decades ago and since then
he's been the best husband
father and friend i could ever imagine
patrick i love you
william patrick's identical twin brother
is here as well
along with his wonderful wife dana
also here from park city utah are
patrick's older brother gardy and his
wife natalie
and last but certainly not least
my very dear in-laws the matriarch and
patriarch of the jackson family pamela
and gardner-jackson have traveled here
from boston to be with me today
i'm saving a special moment in this
introduction for my daughters
talia and laila
girls i know it has not been easy as
i've tried to navigate the challenges of
juggling my career and motherhood
and i fully admit that i did not always
get the balance right
but i hope that you've seen that with
hard work determination
and love it can be done
i am so looking forward to seeing what
each of you chooses to do with your
amazing lives
in this incredible country
i love you so much
there are so many others who are not
here today but whom i need to
acknowledge
i have a large extended family on both
sides they are watching from florida
north carolina new jersey connecticut
new york massachusetts colorado and
beyond
i also have incredible friends three of
my college roommates came here today to
support me
and i have so many other boosters from
miami palmetto senior high school
harvard undergrad harvard law school and
all throughout my personal and
professional life
i've also had extraordinary mentors like
my high school debate coach fran berger
may she rest in peace
she invested fully in me including
taking me to harvard the first i'd ever
really thought of it
to enter a speech competition
mrs berger believed in me
and in turn
i believed in myself
in the category of great mentors
it was also my great good fortune to
have had the chance to clerk for three
brilliant jurists
u.s district judge patty sarris u.s
court of appeals judge bruce celia
and supreme court justice stephen breyer
these extraordinary people were
exceptional role models justice breyer
in particular not only gave me the
greatest job any young lawyer could ever
hope to have
but he also exemplifies what it means to
be a supreme court justice of the
highest level of skill
and integrity civility
and grace
it is extremely humbling to be
considered for justice briar's seat and
i know
that i could never fill his shoes
but if confirmed
i would hope
to carry on his spirit
on the day of his supreme court
nomination
justice breyer said quote
what is law supposed to do
seen as a whole
it is supposed to allow
all people
all people
to live together in a society
where they have so many different views
so many different needs
to live together in a way that is more
harmonious
that is better
so that they can work productively
together
end quote
i could not have said it better myself
members of this committee
if i am confirmed i commit to you
that i will work productively
to support and defend the constitution
and this grand experiment of american
democracy that has endured
over these past 246 years
i have been a judge
for nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent
very seriously
i decide cases from a neutral posture
i evaluate the facts
and i interpret and apply the law to the
facts of the case before me without fear
or favor
consistent with my judicial oath
i know that my role as a judge is a
limited one
that the constitution empowers me only
to decide cases and controversies that
are properly presented
and i know that my judicial role is
further constrained
by careful adherence to precedent
now in preparing for these hearings you
may have read some of my more than 570
written decisions and you may have also
noticed that my opinions tend to be on
the long
side that is because i also believe in
transparency
that people should know precisely what i
think
and the basis for my decision
and all of my professional experiences
including my work as a public defender
and as a trial judge
have instilled in me the importance of
having each litigant
know that the judge in their case has
heard them whether or not their
arguments prevail in court
during this hearing
i hope that you will see
how much i love our country
and
the constitution
and the rights that make us free
i stand on the shoulders of
so many who have come before me
including judge constance baker motley
who was the first african-american woman
to be appointed to the federal bench and
with whom
i share a birthday
and like judge motley
i have dedicated my career
to ensuring that the words engraved on
the front of the supreme court building
equal justice under law
are a reality
and not just
an ideal
thank you
for this historic chance
to join the highest court
to work
with brilliant colleagues to inspire
future generations
and to ensure
liberty
and justice
for all
thank you judge jackson
well this is the end of the first day of
the first three days which
are
involving more personal on a personal
level the senators on the judiciary
committee in a way it's the easiest day
because 10 minutes is merely a throat
clearing warm up for most senators on
this committee
starting tomorrow will be some serious
exchange in questions of 30 minutes and
then the following day 20 minutes for
each senator to participate in this
we're looking forward to this
opportunity to finally really give you a
fulsome opportunity to respond to many
of the things that you've heard and to
answer direct questions members have
until thursday at 5 pm to submit
questions for the record we're going to
reconvene tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
to begin the 30 minute rounds of
questions we thank all the participants
and members of
our audience
for keeping this
dignified respectful and civilized we
hope to continue that tradition tomorrow
with this the committee stands adjourned
thank you
uh